[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
jour 2 du de la Cup donc artificial
intelligence intelligence artificielle
la coupe qui met en valeur cette
intelligence artificielle qui a
révolutionné notre jeu est tellement
d'autres choses on est dans ce jour 2
j'ai oublié de changer c'est les
demi-finales aujourd'hui oh là là autant
pour moi et évidemment évidemment que
c'est les demi-finales parce que hier
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier
il s'est passé il s'est passé beaucoup
de choses
Maxime va chez Lagrave notamment abattu
chaque rillard
m'avait dit aujourd'hui hier il a battu
Ali resa firuga bien dis donc j'en perds
mon latin en ce début de
n'importe quoi j'ai oublié de mettre le
mode studio ce que je vais faire tout de
suite
et je vais changer ça pendant que je
vous parle et donc voilà on a
aujourd'hui à l'IRESA firojack qui n'est
pas éliminé
et qui aura aujourd'hui et bien un
appariement
écoutez on sait pas trop si ce que ça
vaut ce lasavik c'est très fort c'est
sûr mais est-ce que
[Musique]
est-ce que
est-ce que ça va être assez pour
bousculer notre ami à lire ça on espère
pas on va tout de suite
revenir voilà vers là et on est en
demi-finale voilà qu'à lancer toujours
15 + 3 le premier c'est à 1 et demi
simplement parce que ce sont des c'est
le loser bracket donc c'est plus que
deux parties
et effectivement il y a s'il y a un
partout on a un Armageddon immédiat et
ensuite et ensuite à partir de grosso
modo 20h 19h50 20h quand c'est terminé
quand c'est dommage sont terminés on
avait comme un gui dans l'autre tableau
et bien on aura les vainqueurs et donc
les vainqueurs se sont car ça dépend
d'un côté les demi-finales la
demi-finale Carson n'est pas bien Chi et
de l'autre côté Maxime va chez la gravé
évidemment qu'on suivra en priorité
face à chacun
comme vous pouvez le voir loser on aura
one donc c'est Nakamura Guiri et Ali
resa notre jeune ami Ali Reza contre
[Musique]
Denis la zavie et bon moi j'espère que
tout va bien pour vous écoutez moi je
suis très content de vous retrouver on
regarde un petit peu les joueurs Maxime
Vacher La Grave évidemment qui a été
très impressionnant hier
Ikao Nakamura
ensuite qui a perdu aussi hier face à ma
muscarsen
ensuite on a Yann des pommiers à Chi
qui jouera qui jouera aujourd'hui face à
Magnus Carson l'ogre norvégien qui n'en
finit plus de gagner et voilà il est là
32 ans en Norvège de 1938 sur cheesecom
mais voilà très très impressionnant ces
dernières semaines le grand Magnus
alliésa notre petit peu toujours gagner
le tournoi on le rappelle
et d'autres joueurs donc le format vous
le voyez là le
les dates c'est du 25 au 29 septembre
donc c'est en ce moment même jusqu'à
jusqu'au 19 pourquoi à parce que
artificial intelligence donc on célèbre
l'intelligence artificielle je peux même
vous lire exactement
depuis que garikasmaff a perdu contre
diblue en 1997
hop je change de scène ah c'est pas
évident de tout faire depuis que sport
enfin perdu contre eux ces fameux en 97
contre du Blue
l'artifice l'intelligence artificielle a
transformé les échecs maintenant
chaise.com
la plus grande plateforme du jeu d'échec
au monde et
là on se retournois pour célébrer tout
ce qu'a fait l'intelligence artificielle
aux échecs et voilà on peut ça ne
s'arrête pas aux échecs mais évidemment
c'est particulièrement impressionnant
dans le jeu d'échec on l'a vu aussi avec
Deep mind et Google donc qui a créé un
super ordinateur ça devrait pas tarder à
commencer évidemment là j'ai la partie
d'hier
entre
notre ami
Maxime et il faut que je mette le la
pendule aussi 21 secondes c'est ça et
hop là j'avais pas mis les pendules on
va mettre la pendule
je suis pas sûr
ouh là là
non non non non
ça c'est bon et oui là pendule des Noirs
hop là que j'avais pas réglé donc on a
0-0 qui allait bloquer les Noirs je n'en
sais rien
je n'en sais absolument rien on va
regarder si
on a quelque chose de ce côté ou de
l'autre
en tout cas pas de partie lancée ici
ici on va voir mais ça va sous vos yeux
ébahis ça va se lancer bientôt
quart de finale toutes les rondes non
pour l'instant on n'a rien donc pour
l'instant on reste sur ça on va voir ça
bientôt
mais Ali resa donc il y aura les blancs
et toute façon c'est des parties
aller-retour et donc effectivement
aller-retour un blanc un noir et ensuite
ce fameux format d'Armageddon
assez
[Musique]
excitant avec 15 minutes pour les blancs
quoi qu'il arrive et ce système
d'enchères ou les blancs ou les Noirs
donnent leur temps les deux joueurs
proposent un temps celui qui a le temps
plus bas ramasser les Noirs c'est-à-dire
que si elle est Raisa en cas d'un
partout à l'irza dit 9 minutes 32 la
zavik dit 10 minutes 32 et bien allez ça
aura les Noirs à 9 minutes 32 donc faut
pas faire trop bas mais assez bas quand
même pour avoir les noirs et on a le
droit de faire nul alors après il y a
plusieurs écoles on a vu chacun ma
meilleure offre hier qui a gagné qui a
perdu le tirage au sort entre guillemets
qui est proposé un temps beaucoup plus
haut avec les Noirs donc il y a eu les
blancs mais qui a gagné la partie avec
des blancs donc il y a aussi ce cas là
où on gagne avec les Blancs
ma collector aujourd'hui et oui et oui
les mec corpo
avec la misule
alors on va voir tout de suite si ça
alors j'ai tenté un autre truc pour
suivre les parties on m'a donné un autre
lien
pas l'impression que ça marche
peut-être pas
j'ai pas l'impression d'être admin en
fait c'est ça le problème à mon avis
mais c'est pas sûr tout ça
alors on aura Nakamura guéri d'abord
et ensuite fil rouge à lasavik qui
commence deux minutes plus tard ok donc
il y a 2 minutes de décalage est-ce
qu'on a la partie du grand e-caru ou pas
alors est-ce qu'on a la partie du
carreaux tableau des gagnants non je
l'ai pas
je l'ai pas pour l'instant mais ça ne
devrait pas tarder masquer les parties
terminées et vous voyez on n'a pas de
partie du coup
pas de partir on va faire ça
un impôts
ça n'a pas commencé
mais ça ne saurait tarder on a Ali resa
ici à l'écran
mvl évidemment mvl on l'a mvl on l'aura
plus tard plus tard mvl en deuxième
partie de soirée évidemment le tableau
des gagnants qui joue après le tableau
des perdants donc on va évidemment voir
tout ça ensemble une longue soirée mais
une belle soirée
parce qu'on y verra plus clair soit les
raisins peut être éliminée dès ce soir
si il perd contre les avis qui leur a
perdu deux matchs il sera éliminé
tandis que Maxime va chez Lagrave le
loisir de perdre un match et de rester
dans la course à ce magnifique
trophée que je vais vous montrer parce
que je dois le montrer
puis il est beau en plus
le trophée du tournoi magnifique
alors on revient là et pour l'instant on
n'a pas de partie
c'est bizarre j'ai pas de partie est-ce
que j'ai une partie là-bas ou pas
non toujours pas toujours pas de partie
[Musique]
ouais non ça se ça se lève du côté d'Ali
resa
donc a priori on va laisser comme ça
quand même plus sympa de voir ça mais ça
se lève mais on sait toujours pas
si ça commence ou pas ah il y a les
mauvais noms
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire là
je change moi espérons qu'elle est blanc
dans la première
on espère vraiment ça
est-ce que dites-moi si les parties oui
un système de loser bracket
est-ce que je vais regarder sur mon
téléphone si il est parti en commencer
parce que
je suis jamais complètement sûr
looser non je crois que ça a pas
commencé donc il y a un léger un léger
contretemps là
non j'ai pas de partie n'a qu'à moi et à
les raisins on va bien les blancs dans
la première donc ça ça tombe très très
bien
ça c'est quand même une très très bonne
nouvelle je vais voir si 10 quelque
chose dans le chat discussion
technical delay ok léger
léger problème
[Musique]
qui se moque de
chat de
zoom il dit chat
alors
on va voir on va voir ce qui se passe
mais pour l'instant ça n'a pas commencé
ce qui se passe
alors
pour l'instant il n'y a pas
il y a pas grand chose je vais essayer
de faire un petit coup de refresh et on
a on a au moins Nakamura contre guéri à
se mettre sous la dent donc ça sera
mieux que rien attends est-ce que le
direct marche pas très bien oh là là
qui commence tambour battant B3 D5 qui
veut vraiment pas jouer la théorie mais
alors attention contre la niche quand
même il faut le prendre au sérieux le
père Aniche il peut être il peut être
dangereux
ouais ouais bien sûr
Iker ou en premier sur la chaîne US mais
nous on va surveiller évidemment à
l'IRESA
clairement il commence avec deux minutes
de retard allez résa donc
on va faire on va faire un lien je vais
mettre un truc là pour voir si ça a pas
commencé et dès que ça commence en
switch bon c'est pas du tout dangereux
ce qui fait notre ami Nakamura c'est un
peu n'importe quoi mais bon on donne le
centre pour rien
à faire ce qui est bien en bon je sais
pas je sais pas comment il fait
mais en tout cas il le fait et il le
fait très bien qui suis-je pour
critiquer en tout cas il cherche pas à
gagner dans les ouvertures c'est assez
certain que c'est 6 par exemple
peut-être des quatre souvent pour
essayer de boucher de fou et les noirs
sont en général assez confortable mais
bon après c'est le
c'est un handicaru d'arriver à faire des
choses que le commun des mortels
n'arrivent pas à faire et croyez-moi
c'est pas évident à faire ce genre de
choses on voit chez Magnus Carlsen tout
va bien au niveau du du petit
du boîtier sings tout va bien on le voit
voilà c'est ce petit boîtier qui mesure
la qualité de l'air l'humidité la
température
et vous permet de de vérifier que vous
évoluez dans un environnement très sain
et c'est bien le cas
ouais il va être théorie coûte que tout
à fait
Fabi
je sais pas si je prononce bien
parce que contre à Nice c'est quand même
son gros point fort son gros point fort
c'est quand même les ouvertures et Ali
resa a commencé alors on va tout de
suite se mettre chez
et avec ça ouais donc on a les raisins
avec les Blancs est-ce que mon truc
marche ou pas
non ça marche pas du tout
ok donc là
c'est un mauvais lien donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je vais revenir vers le
vers le truc normal et je vais aller
choper la partie quelque part
et je vais la choper ici donc vous avez
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude je
répéterai jamais assez vous avez donc à
ma droite l'échiquier le Grand Échiquier
celui où j'analyse où je monte des
choses où je fais des flèches un peu de
manière compulsive parfois
vous voyez hop hop
hop
tandis que sur le petit échec qui est en
bas et bien vous avez le direct vous
pouvez réfléchir à votre rythme et
il faut juste changer les noms
ah ben ça c'est bien vu ça
et oui tout à fait il faut juste changer
les noms effectivement
et je fais ça je m'exécute
je m'exécute en direct
et on a Denise lazavie que la jeune
jeune prodige
qui est un peu la surprise c'est
champions mais en même temps
surprise surprise à moitié c'est normal
d'avoir des surprises
en fait c'est ça c'est ça le truc c'est
que c'est normal complètement normal
d'avoir des surprises parce que non
seulement il y a eu le confinement donc
on n'a pas pu mesurer tous les progrès
il a été très bon au championnats du
monde rapide et Blitz donc c'est
vraiment une demi surprise mais je
voudrais bien à ce niveau il prend ça
très au sérieux vous voyez son attitude
il est très concentré il joue tous les
title Tuesday
et
ah là là j'ai mal écrit son prénom oh là
là oh là là vraiment vraiment
il me pardonnera j'en suis certain
et voilà donc c'est normal et cette
période de confinement où on n'a pas pu
suivre les progrès exacts de chacun et
il joue beaucoup sur Internet il est
très très fort
ça s'écrit comme ça c'est absolument
certain tu peux aller vérifier
alors A5 c'est pour prendre de l'espace
à l'eldom c'est le concept quand on les
Noirs ont joué à 6 on les puni en
prenant de l'espace on va jouer B4 qui
est BD2 et finale on peut s'organiser
des C4 B5 ou des B5 directement ça prend
l'espace alors effectivement ça refuse
pas du tout l'italienne ou le 4-5 mais
c'est une façon de jouer qui ma foi est
assez intéressante on a pu voir les
raisins hier qui est un peu lent à mon
goût
mais
effectivement il est
on espère qu'il va jouer un peu plus
rapidement il était face à Maxime en
forme de gala en ce moment très en forme
aussi on espère vraiment que Maxime qui
a un très bon score un très gros score
de Maxime contre ma média off donc
effectivement on peut on peut espérer le
voir au plus haut niveau
et on espérer revoir une finale mvl mvl
Magnus avec une deuxième chance pour
l'un des deux donc on peut voir deux
matchs mvl Magnus ça serait très beau
mais ça serait un match intéressant ça
c'est une certitude vu la forme
du moment de Maxime et évidemment de
Magnus qui gagne à peu près tout ce qui
joue et c'est de bonne augure évidemment
pour ce grand Suisse qui aura lieu fin
octobre à l'île de Man avec tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde qui vont
tenter de décrocher une
une place dans les deux places qui sont
données
pour les prochains candidats
qui est un objectif évidemment majeur
pour aller résa firoja et Maxime va
chier la grave alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à 5 x 7 c'est des petites
subtilités fou B3 donc ça indique qu'on
veut pas échanger ce fou sur fou aussi a
été joué et x 4 fous des 7
qui déclen clairement parce qu'il y
avait il y avait un clou h par là et
maintenant je vous cabd2 pourquoi on
peut pas prendre à 5 et bien parce qu'on
prendrait ici dame prend et tu reprends
cavalier donc on protège en fait
indirectement le pion A5 avec ce four à
4 c'est intéressant alors en général les
Noirs s'organisent en jouant cavalier 7
kg 6 pour essayer ensuite de pousser ces
6 suivi de pousser libératrice entre
guillemets elle a poussé centrale des 6
des 5
peut-être faire des 5 directement quoi
que ça me paraîtrait un peu tôt
intéressant en tout cas
on va voir ce que fait
la zavie que le jeune joueur
biélorus je crois alors je sais pas s'il
est d'origine russe et il a changé je
sais pas exactement
pour être très honnête
ouais
Fiero est déjà qualifié pour la grande
finale à Toronto alors ça c'est possible
c'est tout à fait possible
on verra tout ça mais en tout cas la
fille à la Toronto pour ce
qui ne voient pas voilà c'est la grande
finale du champions 9 osseuse 2019 au 16
décembre qui sera joué en direct et donc
ça sera du eSport le vrai eSport c'est à
dire ça sera sur place
et
[Musique]
sur des ordinateurs aussi donc
intéressant
de voir tout ça
dans la même pièce mais sur ordi donc
pas sur échiquier KBD de cavaleo 7 a été
joué comme je vous l'annonçais fou c'est
deux on revient on va pas échanger ses
fous et G6 et des 4 si on arrive à faire
des quatre avant que les Noirs jouent
des 6 dessins alors c'est pas un
désastre pour les Noirs mais quand même
on a obtenu un petit plus parce que
c'est 5 me semble pas évident parce que
c'est ça affaibli quand même grandement
le pion en V6 on pourrait imaginer
quelque chose comme ça celui qui est C4
ou qui est C4 directement
qui attaque des 6 et ça serait pas
évident pour les noirs de gérer tout ça
l'ordi aime pas du tout mes coups
peut-être qu'il veut faire des seins ici
mais bon et ensuite peut-être qu'elle
est C4 et c'est vrai que ce fou ça quand
même pas mal en muret derrière ses
propres pions donc c'est ça c'est pas
pas trop jouable dessin qui s'y doit pas
marcher
et donc des petites questions se pose au
noir comment on fait peut-être
qu'on va faire peut-être B3 ou B4 ou B2
et on va essayer d'améliorer gentiment
notre structure
prendre de l'espace pour pas cher et les
Noirs ce qui font c'est pas très clair
on va voir ça sera commenté en français
oui oui ça sera commenté en français ça
c'est une évidence
mais je renomme pas le titre du coup
c'est quoi le titre
oui bah oui il y a ça et d'autres choses
c'est pas moi qui fait les titres
c'est pas moi qui fait les titres mvl ça
sera un peu plus tard
mais on va on va tout regarder
évidemment
et il faut ces 6 vous voyez pour faire
pression sur ce pion sans rendre
possible car il a fait un tour à trois
ouais ça c'est une idée aussi très
fréquente dans ce genre de position
en fait on sous-entend que les Noirs ne
doivent pas prendre parce qu'on va
reprendre et ensuite la tour passera
soit là soit là et donc c'est un coup
utile à long terme et on voit les
raisins qui jouent très vite qui met une
grosse pression
quasi 6 minutes d'avance pour aller
raisin alors Ali Reza qui est pas motivé
il y a quand même des gros prix dans ces
tournois donc je pense qu'il est il est
motivé
ça fait jamais plaisir de perdre donc il
va quand même il va donner le meilleur
de lui-même il a pas perdu il peut
encore gagner le tournoi on le rappelle
une défaite c'est pas c'est pas
rédhibitoire c'est pas éliminatoire
c'est du double élimination un peu comme
ça se fait au basket-ball
mais donc clairement il va il va jouer
sa chance à fond et joue vite j'ai
l'impression parce qu'il connaît la
position tout simplement et ça paraît
d'un point de vue noir moi qui ai joué
beaucoup d'italienne avec les Noirs je
serai un peu je serai pas content de mon
ouverture alors évidemment
tout le monde comprend très bien que les
noirs sont objectivement pas beaucoup
moins bien
mais
ça reste quand même
assez dur à jouer je trouve
nazi qu'il a que les lois rapide je n'en
sais rien ça se Google très vite goulian
et ça sera pas
ça sera pas vraiment une grosse
indication de son Elo rapide en tout cas
fidèle parce que il a probant pas
tellement joué mais online il est à 2756
tandis que airesa 2794 sur plusieurs
choses comme il joue sur C8 alors ça
c'est pas c'est pas un coup
que je veux avoir ça peut être facile de
expliquer ce couteau C8
je n'ai pas du tout la réf alors
peut-être pour empêcher des dessins que
vous des 7 peut-être c'est ça la ref
c'est que voilà sur un truc comme ça où
on prend de l'espace et bien on va jouer
c'est si c'est la colonne C va s'ouvrir
c'est la seule explication de Tours C8
que je vois et aussi il voit pas trop
quoi faire il sait pas trop quoi faire
il a 7,45 il s'est dit je joue un coup
il faut jouer à un moment quelque chose
qui détériore pas ma position
et donc
voilà c'est ça le c'est ça l'idée
à Toronto il y a un demi million un
price poule
sur Google il y a 17 ans il est à 35 sur
sa came c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas ça
va c'est les lunettes ça c'est un truc
c'est
de la lune étoffobi mon cher
non alors non super cam26 allez Azay
combien tient au Champions il est bien
au champions tours je pense qu'il est
déjà qualifié
l'année premier j'ai pas regardé le
classement c'est une bonne idée de
regarder le classement vous pouvez
trouver ça sur Championship Store de com
vous avez tout le classement donc
n'hésitez pas à aller voir
mais ça joue pas dans le Grand Prix
fidèle qui qualifie pour les candidats
il y a que des tournois live en direct
c'est à dire en réel et pas sur Internet
qui compte qui compte pour pour ce genre
de qualification pour l'instant pour
l'instant à mon avis tout ça va évoluer
évidemment
salut rodoendron c'est le loser bracket
tout à fait
tout à fait c'est le looser bracket mais
attention le looser bracket loser d'un
jour
winner dans notre jour peut-être
et il prend l'espace comme je vous
l'avais dit peut-être qu'il prépare la
poussée des cinq suites C4 c'est pas
impossible aussi et quand même une
option
et plus que 6 minutes pour les avis qui
sait pas trop comment la jouer cette
position il a joué de tour C8 qui était
quand même un aveu de faiblesse
clairement
et donc voilà ici c'est pas il sait pas
quoi faire
cavalier H7 ok c'est assez thématique
pour essayer de mettre le cavalier ici
peut-être la dame par là lequel un F4
c'est de monter une attaque plus ou
moins mais encore une fois on va pas
trop où ça va et la zavie qui a très
très mal géré le début de partie là
clairement
c'est pas bon du tout
n'hésitez pas tandis que streamlabs vous
le rappelle n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
à notre chaîne YouTube à notre chaîne
twitch et comme ça vous ne ratez rien
likez les vidéos et laissez des
commentaires évidemment faites tout ça
ça nous fait un retour et c'est
inestimable merci d'avance
un petit pouce fait plaisir ça coûte
rien
alors cavalier H7 et maintenant elle ira
maintenant qu'on a enlevé la pression
sur ça on peut on peut s'organiser de ce
côté mais de créer en G3 c'est toujours
une bonne affaire en général ce qui est
un G3 parce que ça libère la diagonale
du fou
donc c'est intéressant de faire ça
en Bleach j'aurais cavalier alors c'est
pas du c'est pas du Blitz et c'est pas
moi qui joue
alors
le système des candidats
il y a la Coupe du Monde 3 places
il y a le grand Suisse deux places il y
a des pommier à chi le perdant du
du match précédent
la septième place c'est le premier et
l'eau au premier janvier 2024 celui qui
est premier et l'eau au 1er janvier 2024
il est qualifié si Magnus Carlsen veut
pas jouer c'est le deuxième si le
deuxième est aussi qualifié ça doit être
Ding ou nepo elle est en prend le
troisième et la dernière place c'est une
sorte de système qui a inventé la
fidélité à travers tous les tournois en
marque des points par exemple les tours
de vaikanzé les toits de l'île de Man
les tours de la Coupe du monde
voilà le système de points les parties
rapides aussi quand je champion du monde
rapide et Blitz quant aussi et voilà ce
système de points et qui est complexe
qui est évidemment complexe et c'est le
premier à ça qui gagne pour la santé qui
mène et vu la saison qui réalise notre
jeune ami Google pour l'instant sa place
au candidat serait moins d'être volée
donc on verra on verra qui sera le
qualifié mais je crois que ça se jouait
entre Google et guéri parce que guéri a
fait un très bon départ en gagnant avec
un zé mais effectivement
il s'est fait rattraper les grandes
chaises tours
les quoi j'ai cessé c'est quoi
ranchestre je pense que ça compte ouais
champions ça compte pas parce que c'est
online
c'est pas retransmis sur chaise 24 oh là
Terracan c'est étonnant c'est étonnant
les parties sont retransmises est-ce
qu'ils ont mis le live ou pas moi j'ai
arrêté de demander parce que c'est
l'enfer
alors j'ai vu une question Ali est très
loin dans le classement mais oui il faut
jouer
il faut jouer pour ça il faut bien jouer
donc il joue pas assez notre ami alias
exactement tu as tout à fait raison
c'est un scène qui nous pose une
question bonjour est-ce que le gagnant
du loser bracket doit-il gagner par deux
fois le vainqueur du Winner Bracket tout
à fait quand le vainqueur de winner
broken n'a jamais perdu effectivement le
dernier jour il y a une grande finale
entre le vainqueur du loser mackett et
le vainqueur de winner bracket
si le vainqueur du loser bracket gagne
on joue un deuxième match
on prend les deux mêmes et on recommence
et donc il a droit à une deuxième chance
le vainqueur de winner bracket qui a une
logique un placable il a gagné tous ces
matchs et a perdu un seul et donc il a
le droit à une deuxième chance
comme tout le monde est fou B2 je vous
avais parlé de ce fou B2 on met ce faux
social grand diagonale peut-être ces
quatre va arriver et on n'a pas peur des
fantômes ouais il fait que j'ai 5 quand
même ça paraît logique alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on prend ici ou
est-ce qu'on laisse bon je vois pas
tellement d'urgence à prendre j'ai
l'impression que c'est 4 va arriver
quand même tôt ou tard
ça peut être l'idéal où on peut prendre
et en remettre une couche avec l'autre
cavalier un beau relais de cavaliers ici
et une belle avance au temps
pour Ali Reza
ces trois C4 jouer
par notre ami Ali Rosa
et évidemment on fait jouer la tour
foudènes on revient il sait pas trop
quoi faire laservic c'est logique parce
qu'il y avait des dessins que c'est ça
qui allait arriver se fout faisait plus
rien c'est 6 s'il a déjà fait quelque
chose ça c'est pas très clair
mais clairement
il est beaucoup mieux là à l'IRESA un
très très beau centre regardez-moi cette
phalange de pions on a plus d'espace
donc on a un avantage c'est une
certitude peut-être c'est quatre C5 pour
définitivement
en murer ce fond à 7
et on va voir comment se débrouiller
notre ami à lirea peut-être qu'elle
prend G5 pour déjà faire coulisser la
tour ça peut être intéressant ça aussi
et on voit cette tour de A1 qui a réussi
à s'activer c'est ça le
c'est ça la magie de cette position
voilà évidemment il y a les autres
divisions mais qu'on suit pas
salut
Corto M34 salut à tous dans le chat
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit message
à poser une question c'est une question
vous turlupine vous n'êtes certainement
pas le seul à vous la poser
merci c'est gentil c'est gentil que
T'choupi
mvl c'est après ça
deuxième partie de soirée
c'est ça c'est le grand format
et ça paraît être un désastre pour les
Noirs la zavik très en difficulté dans
ce début de match
face aux jeunes princes
oui après alors après après c'est vers
20h en gros grosso modo c'est vers 20h
peut-être avant peut-être un peu après
et oui non alors
j'ai oublié gouliane excellente question
je pensais que ça joue en quatre parties
mais indiqué qu'un ennemi et pas deux et
demi et oui parce que ça se joue en
quatre parties dans le winner bracket
tandis que dans loser
bracket ça se joue en simplement deux
parties plus en amaguent on passe à la
vitesse supérieure
voilà tout ça pour jouer deux matchs à
un moment dans la même journée je crois
que c'est pas aujourd'hui
mais en tout cas on reste sur ça gus gus
parce que sinon
on s'en sort pas si on suit plusieurs
parties en rapide on s'en sort pas mais
en tout cas je peux dire un coup d'oeil
je vais garder un coup d'œil je vais
jeter un coup d'oeil rapide
et guéri est complètement gagnant
apparemment contre caroom à kamura ça
c'est quand même une surprise
américain en difficulté
j'ai pas envie de jouer le tatouage des
je joue assez rarement le Time Tuesday
honnêtement
donc peut-être à 23 heures je peux
prolonger le stream pour jouer le title
ça fera une ça fera une journée très
longue quand même
un commentaire sympa sur YouTube
comment j'ai pu perdre mon accent là on
est
et bien écoute certaines personnes ne
remarquent
cet accent anglais donc faut avoir une
oreille assez finie en le remarque
et il a perdu car on Nakamura avec les
Blancs et bien ça c'est quand même une
grosse surprise
victoire de guéri dans la première donc
une nulle suffit
exactement gouliane ah ok du coup si en
grande finale le winner pair il joue ça
en deux manches plus Armageddon tout à
fait il joue ça en deux parties
d'un projet 5 jouets je crois qu'on va
voir une tour atterrir vers G3 regardez
ce fou qui est quand même le gros
problème de la position
qui a empêché le tour des trois mais pas
tout j'ai trois ni ton F3 d'ailleurs
donc les deux sont vraiment intéressants
et maintenant
comment il va faire
et réfléchis à lire et ça il a bien
raison ton G3 jouets avec gain de temps
c'est pas mal parce que ça ça va être en
l'air si par exemple la dame revient ici
voilà on peut maintenant jouer trois et
menacer tout reprend Jessie déstabiliser
la position noire ça sent très bon
franchement pour aller raisin j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup sa position qui
n'aimerait pas avec ce fou un set qui
est complètement en muré foubetroide
tellement naturel maintenant
dur de résister de pas jouer fou B3
franchement je vois pas de
contre-indication faudrait vraiment
qu'il y ait une grosse contre-indication
pour que je joue pas fou mais trop en
cette position
on va voir ce que ça donne
salut à toi de people
vous pouvez trois je vois même pas il va
bouger son roi peut-être
s'il fait KF4 dmg4 attention
comment on fait pour protéger c'est déjà
pas évident de parler le matin un coup
là dame F6 peut-être mais bon imaginons
cavalier F3 on ramène encore une pièce
ça peut être vraiment un désastre
alors ton g3d réflexion d'aller résa
comment fait-on
tout à fait à l'époque je faisais des
retours et c'est vrai et je râlais tout
le temps
je vois qu'il y a des il y a des il y a
des vieux de la vieille dans le chat qui
se rappellent une fois
ouais
je suis tenu comme tout donc quand
j'arrive pas à mon à mon objectif hello
et bien j'en mets une couche alors
damage 5 ok empêche cavalier F4 à cause
de ça
coûte prévention peut-être plus malin
peut-être qu'il veut faire passer le
cavalier aussi et faire foudre au moment
opportun peut-être il considère d'un
match 5 et plus fort comme ça il y a
plus de cavalier F4 du tout
et un coup un peu aussi surprenant pour
les trois minutes de lasavik ça marche
pas de pain de surprendre
et on voit la zavie qui est quand même
dans le dur là
alors comment on fait avec avec les
Noirs c'est c'est une torture tour des 8
qui apparemment une faute décisive
d'après la jauge je suppose que le coup
ça attaque ça attaque le cavalier le
coup naturel qu'on a envie de jouer tout
de suite c'est cavalier F3 évidemment
qui n'est pas le coup gagnant
dans le coup gagnant est-ce que ça
serait pas fou B3 c'est l'autre coup
qu'on a envie de jouer pour le menacer
d'un projet 6
encore mieux certainement
ah ouais c'est très agréable et sur wash
7 comment ça marche je vois pas la fin
qui F3 certainement et 3 a été joué par
notre ami à les réserves ça sent très
bon pour aller résa ça veut dire rouage
7 va certainement être joué quoi d'autre
cavalier F4 on joue sur tous les
clouages en menace dame prend G6 tours
des deux et vraiment pas bon dame prend
G6 comment on fait pour protéger ici
peut-être dame fuite mais à ce moment-là
fou c'est au minimum et celui de fou
prendre 6 terminado les carottes sont
cuites pour les noirs
donc on doit jouer roi H7 certainement
et maintenant peut-être qu'avec trois
qui est G5 quelque chose comme ça
c'est plus agréable c'est une position
gagnante pour les blancs c'est une
certitude
comment on fait avec les noirs laservic
qui est certainement en train de
chercher une solution qui n'existe de
toute façon pas roi et fuite ouh là là
là là mais bon en même temps on avait
pas de bon conseil à lui donner cavalier
F3 a l'air très fort ici
très simple et très fort attention parce
que tout reprend des deux quand même une
menace
quand même alors il y a mieux
apparemment bon je sais pas ce que c'est
peut-être que les raisins va le voir les
raisins qui fait une masterclass pour
l'instant clairement
non on leur dit il pourrait pas défendre
non je vais mettre je vais tricher un
peu pour voir les valves
c'est il ton rêve 3 et c'est plus 3 pour
les blancs donc tout F3 cavalier FK le
meilleur c'est ça ouais mais j'aurais
jamais ça et cavalier F3 est en fait la
conclusion c'est qu'il y a trop
d'attaque
et ça va être madame G4 menace mais non
c'est pas du tout humain
cette histoire de Tour Eiffel 3 et
sacrifice de qualité cavalier F3 me
semble beaucoup plus humain et c'est
quand même du plus 1,50 après kaf3 il
faut jouer comme les F4 avec des Noirs
5 dames 5
cavaliers H5 et tourgé 4 et bon ben
voilà on est un pion de plus net et
c'est terminé tout simplement
mais attention à les raisins sont péché
mignon hier c'était de se mettre trop
mal au temps
donc faut faire attention à ça
on va voir ce qu'il va faire un lirez un
que BALF 3 est quand même le plus simple
de très loin
pour faire pousser trois aussi à mon
avis il faut ces trois conserves
l'avantage clairement même pas
ok donc faut faire attention pourquoi
cavalier 4
et G6 maintenant ou f6f6 j'aime pas trop
c'est ça peut-être j'ai 6 quelque chose
comme ça
et cavalier 3 vient d'être joué par Ali
resa très logique
et laser
la zavik qui va qui maintenant qui a des
soucis de très gros soucis on peut
montrer de vente assez jolie par exemple
je menace je menace
menace maths et surpris on prend H5 il y
a qui avait les G6 et chaque et mat très
très joli
a été joué par lasavik faute de mieux le
pion va être pris à priori dame G4
semble plus bancal
c'est pas mal aussi pour garder
l'initiative CF6 maintenant je suppose
que les H4 ça a l'air pas mal quand même
menace cavalie F5
ce qui est G6 on a tout un tas de choses
qui semblent assez insupporte assez
insurmontable pour les noirs
et ben
tu es tombé sur une de mes combinaison
dans le bouquin de garde ça va pas
arriver tous les jours
contre qui
ketchupi on va voir la mémoire de catchu
pic qui dit je bossais le calcul aux
échecs de hogal de jour je suis tombé
sur une de tes combinaison
mais trois combinaisons
Mulhouse 2011 ah fuj6 contre Brunner
je t'ai donné la solution là je t'ai
fait un beau spoiler
est-ce que c'est fou G6
dis-moi ça dis-moi
ça va être ça
allez voir
c'est joli c'est pas très dur mais très
esthétique full G6 of course ouais
la vente qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure
oui un pion de plus pour les blancs on
va simplement bouger la tour c'est un
pion central bon la Tour est un peu
bizarre en G4 mais peut-être tu auras
quatre va arriver ça a l'air quand même
complètement gagnant pour les blancs
et ton G4 jouer
tour des trois un peu de jeu quand même
mais bon avec ce fou à 7 ça promet
ça peut pas être assez ça peut jamais
être assez avec un
une pièce aussi mal placé je tourne
trois pour échanger la tour la pièce la
plus active des Noirs ça a beaucoup de
sens tu reprends puis on prend mon
instaurage 4 ensuite
et ça va quand même être très dur
voir impossible tout simplement pour les
noirs
c'est impossible c'est juste perdant 2
minutes contre une allez raisin full
on va voir
on va voir ce que ça donne mais ça a
l'air vraiment vraiment complètement
terminé
puis on prend G5 il essaie d'enfermer la
tour mais normalement ça devrait pas
prendre
mais ça perd du temps apparemment je
suppose que c'est 6 va être joué
et non a été joué
et là on peut pas prendre en menace vous
prend F3 et tout reprend le 5 donc il
faut bouger de fou
là le problème c'est qu'il y a cavalier
F6 mais cavalier F6 je peux tout
simplement donner la qualité ça a l'air
complètement gagnant on a tous les tous
les fous là et un deux trois ça va être
ça va être trop dur là pour les noirs
fouet de fous prends ces 7 jouets par
notre ami Ali resa et ça a l'air
complètement terminé il a raté le
sacrifice de qualité qui est hyper fort
il y a pas de tout recettes parce qu'il
y a toujours fous des 6 et le clouage
cavalier
c'est quasi certain on sacrifie il fait
chèque d'abord ok s'il veut c'est comme
il veut roi G8 alors
on va G7 c'est même faut 5 là qui a
l'air fort moi j'ai 8 et maintenant faut
prendre mais cette va être joué quasi
certainement
et c'est là que le pion A6 c'est pas en
prise mais bon il y a C6 C7 qui va
arriver cahier des quatre qui peut
arriver aussi qui est étranger 4 ah je
prends G4 c'est terminé déjà trois pions
rendez-vous compte 3 pions roi F2 va
arriver c'est gentiment on va chasser ce
fou c'est terminé fou mais c'est un
cahier des cadres va venir c'est
quasiment certain
il peut abandonner notre ami laser
et ouais on a léger décalage comme d'hab
avec les je vais demander ça j'ai oublié
de demander hier mais de plus avoir ce
décalage Ali raza qui s'est déjà levé ça
veut dire qu'il a gagné c'est un spoiler
mais bon on savait qu'il allait gagner
on nous fait un spoiler alerte qui est
des quatre fous des 7
et là on pousse ah non il prend le pion
mais il a bien raison trois pions c'est
mieux que deux
trois pions passer lié oh là là regardez
ce fou qui va être complètement dominé
et je pense qu'il a dû abandonner notre
ami la vie c'est terminé il est pas bien
ouais
je peux avoir je pense que je peux avoir
les
[Musique]
le truc pour avoir les les parties en
live
ouais ouais désolé désolé
je crois que c'est ma faute honnêtement
si Nathan il regarde est-ce qu'il peut
régler ça j'envoie un petit message on
va pas en ce temps ce qu'on va faire
c'est que Ali resa dans la suivante
et bien il aura les noirs
comment ça se fait ça
ils sont tous les deux d'accord donc on
va tourner regardez hop là t'express
pour vous servir on va mettre allez les
amis
c'est fait en deux secondes
et on va mettre la zavie qu'ici et ça
reprend dans 5-6 minutes et moi pour
l'instant je vais essayer de m'organiser
pour voir le flux en direct
merci beaucoup de me suivre et
effectivement c'est la même sur le
stream anglais
ok bah ça ça me rassure un petit peu du
coup
donc allez raisin qui aura le droit de
faire nul pour gagner ce match des
perdants entre guillemets et on se
rejoint tout de suite après une légère
pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis donc de retour pour cette
partie revanche on veut pas me donner
l'accès les méchants
c'est bon on va voir désolé j'ai fait
une petite opération qui était pas
terrible tout à l'heure
de
on voit aliasaki la première
et
donc qu'il y aura les Noirs dans la
deuxième
on aurait pu se mettre l'échiquier du
côté d'Ali resa
on ferait pas ça on aime bien on aime
bien voir du côté d'Ali reser on va on
va tourner les chéquier
on va tourner comment on fait pour ton
échiquier la petite barre et hop et
comme ça et du côté de raisin c'est pas
mal ça
on se fait toujours à livraison en bas
on est content de ça on aime ça parce
qu'on est à fond pour aller raisin
pour l'instant j'ai pas réussi à régler
ce problème de de live mais je pense
qu'ils vont prêter un compte où je peux
voir en direct
ce qui se passe parce que c'est quand
même plus simple alors effectivement
ouais c'est toujours pour éviter
d'éventuelles triches mais là je peux
pas je peux pas enfin bon
bref je réussir à les convaincre que je
suis au-dessus de tout soupçon et que
même
si j'ai très envie qu'elle ira et Maxime
gagne et bien je serai je serai d'une
honnêteté
[Musique]
française non je plaisante
insoupçonnable
je sais pas non c'est pas terrible ça
aurait pas les coups vous inquiétez pas
je peux pas tout faire en même temps je
gère le stream
franchement est-ce que je peux avoir le
flux de caméra avec un délai ouais non
c'est quand même plus simple sans faille
voilà on était sans fin et tout à fait
misclick
ça serait sympa quand même d'avoir ça
ouais un délai sur le flux sur la caméra
là je suis dans un call zoom
ça va être compliqué quand même je
préfère qu'il me donne les parties en
direct
scrupuleuse
non mais bon on peut pas oui
je saurais même pas comment faire en
fait comment je ferais mes comptes je
vous parle je stream le truc
[Musique]
donc voilà je plaiderais l'incompétence
voilà
tu as qui est qui me met le
qui demande
qui demande ça exemplaire
tout à fait il y a des gens qui plaient
dans la faveur parce qu'il y a un type
il me connaît pas il a dit non c'est pas
bon et là j'ai des j'ai lancé un gros
débat sur ce sac
je vous raconte pas
je sais pas
je sais pas ce qui va se passer
faut-il atteindre la fin la fin du
procès de laservic pour voir pour passer
au bourreau au barreau la plaidoirie de
mvl tout à fait j'aime pas perdre
tout à fait
tu as tout à fait raison
on va on va attendre la fin de la
torture laser
donc voilà là ils sont en train de gérer
le truc
il s'est fait
j'adore ça moi j'adore moi j'ai
découvert alors
j'ai découvert je suppose que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent le monde de
l'entreprise moi j'étais indépendante
pendant 20 ans
je l'ai déjà
j'ai déjà ça m'étonnerait quand même
ils me disent que je l'ai déjà en fait
c'est génial
j'aurais fait vraiment
alors secret division ah ouais
ok donc là j'ai les coups en direct
normalement
alors je vais m'excuser
donc ouais donc là j'ai le truc là j'ai
accès en fait
à ça donc je vais le copier et le coller
et j'arrive je suis tout à vous
je suis complètement à vous finalement
ça a été réglé
je dis merci quand même parce que là
j'ai vraiment fait n'importe quoi j'ai
créé un petit truc en fait un petit
débat
qui était si vous voulez déjà réglé
bon écoutez
donc en fait ah ouais c'est ça ok donc
on va voir ce que nous fait à lire et ça
voilà donc là on a les joueurs en direct
et les parties en direct ah vraiment
j'ai pas été bon
j'ai pas été bon mais alors c'était
assez grave de pas être bon à ce
point-là alors on va revenir par là
des quatre lf6 on a une catalane de la
part de laser sur une catalane
très solide pour les noirs
notre ami elle H4 fous et 6 qui a déjà
été joué et on va voir MVF joue juste
après ça
donc si ça se termine tôt mvl joue tôt
si ça se termine tard
c'est aussi simple que ça mais grosso
modo d'ici une heure
et vous aussi ce qui est une ligne assez
connue et très solide pour les Noirs
c'est pas évident
certains ont cherché un avantage dans
cette position et
et
pas beaucoup ont trouvé
alors on a ouais j'ai pas été bon sur ce
coup là parce qu'en plus l'autre il
bosse sur une autre truc
j'ai vraiment je me l'envoyer ce lien
hop là copier je vais me le taux envoyer
voilà ça on aime ça on aime ça envoyer
vous savez vous faites ça vous aussi
vous envoyer des petits messages comme
ça vous oubliez pas les choses
donc
[Musique]
je m'envoie des petits messages voilà
c'est 1-0 le score pour aller résa et
oui et c'est en deux parties cette fois
parce que et j'ai pas mis dans le bon
sens oh j'ai pas mis dans le bon sens
n'importe quoi et oui il y a les raisins
elle est noire dans cette partie
puisqu'il a gagné avec les Blancs
personne ne suit
j'encule tout le monde alors que c'est
moi qui fait des bêtises et oui c'est un
talent alors il joue tourner un Dave à 5
ouais ça c'est connu je crois qu'il y a
foi 6 qui est un coup ici mais en vrai
allez hasard a déjà joué ça va
donc allez régler noir qui peut se
contenter d'une nul fu H6 je sais plus
ce que c'est la ligne je vais allumer la
jauge rouge et 5 aussi jouable
et sur Fougères 5 comment on joue je ne
sais plus et vous êtes il connaît très
bien sa ligne à lire Elsa il va jouer H6
au prochain coup on fait [__] prend on
a l'impression d'avoir l'initiative mais
en fait c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez annulable pour les noirs très
solide salut à toi mon cher bijoux
pour ne pas oublier il suffit de s'en
rappeler alors tout à fait ça c'était il
y a il y a 10 ans maintenant je j'oublie
les choses
c'est terrible
c'était terrible les choses qu'on
travaille régulièrement comme la mémoire
à clico hasard non faux
il y a un léger différé sur le stream et
très léger
et un truc gênant il est parti en direct
Laurence et que même si triche pas toi
il y a quelqu'un qui regarde ton stream
peut lui tricher pour l'un ou l'autre
des joueurs surtout si on sait que ton
Stream est toujours en direct
c'est pas bête mais je crois qu'il y a
un léger délai honnêtement
mais effectivement
alors quel est le cas dame 5 jouer par
aliasa fearuja qui joue toujours très
vite
quelqu'un peut m'envoyer un message avec
leur
avec leur à laquelle il l'envoie s'il
vous plaît
c'est vrai c'est pour ça que les joueurs
sont vérifiés alors ça pourrait être
plus compliqué mais toute façon si
quelqu'un veut se mettre
les salles sont vérifiées donc voilà que
vous soyez en train de regarder ou dans
la dans la pièce d'à côté là où les
joueurs jouent
on peut toujours faire ça 19h01 c'est ça
c'est ça quand même globalement une 45
voilà tonton c'est l'heure de
Bischwiller là parce que moi quand je
reçois à 19h0144 donc tu lui envoies
avant que l'heure soit passé bravo
ouais donc effectivement
une seconde avant c'est du direct pure
et dur
je pensais qu'il y avait un léger
décalage
et ouais on a cette finale de tour ouais
que j'avais déjà regardé je crois que
c'est une partie du nouveau champion de
France Yannick Gozzoli qui a joué cette
partie contre dead chef en Coupe de
France et après tour reprend et roi des
7 il a gagné Yannick mais franchement
c'est quand même très égal cette
position alors après les blancs sont un
petit peu mieux
il y a le son sur la carte ouais il y a
le son il y a le son
sur le cas on est obligé de laisser le
son ouvert quand on joue
donc en fait c'est pas si évident
si pas si évident d'avoir quelqu'un dans
la pièce d'à côté enfin faut organiser
un truc et puis s'il tombe trop la tête
on va le ça va se voir quand même au
bout d'un moment vous voyez
après moi ça m'arrive enfin c'est parti
par exemple d'aller fermer la fenêtre ou
voyez un truc à côté de je sais pas mais
en tout cas les bruits s'entendent le
son est ouvert
donc c'est pas si évident en vrai
toujours possible on peut toujours
contourner les règles s'il y en a envie
mais bon donc le problème le souci ici
pour les Noirs c'est surtout de ne pas
échanger les tours parce que si on
échange les tours
je pense qu'on perd pourquoi parce qu'on
va faire ce fameux petit chemin
et la petite à petit on va être en zone
le roi mais va valer un H6 on va jouer
un petit coup un petit coup par là par
exemple
B3 était peut-être pas le meilleur mais
voilà un truc comme ça c'est ça le
concept
et là on va être quand même plus ou
moins j'ai 4 ans la perte cette finale
de pion
comment la paire exactement est-ce que
cf5 d'abord n'enlève 5 est pas bon donc
faut faire G5 ou alors 5
ouais le 5 va être gagnant
et hop
ça perd ce genre de finale évidemment il
le sait à
donc faire très attention en tout cas
c'est très dangereux
Magnus et défaut je vais en même temps
que Maxime
ah si les Noirs attendent c'est un
problème on va essayer certainement
devenir avec le roi comme ça ouais c'est
ce qui va faire tourger vite bravo
tonton bises
qui nous donne les coups et H4 ok bah H4
c'est un peu bizarre ça ça crée pas de
bon scénario avec le roi qui arrive par
là
donc j'aime pas trop H4 honnêtement les
noirs peuvent faire même peut-être F5
pour essayer de se dédoubler les pions
ça peut être intéressant
ouais voilà on peut imaginer du morse
mais bon
c'est risqué quand même c'est risqué et
il y a pas de raison de honnêtement il y
a eu l'épisode cramique mais bon
il y a quand même
[Musique]
pas mal de
paranoïa dans tout ça
bon même si elle est paranoïa quand
parfois raison aussi c'est toujours
pareil
mais là il a globalement tort alors
effectivement
en tête Tuesday par exemple quand il y a
pas les caméras effectivement il y a
plus de chances de tricher mais c'est
bien fait leur truc de
contrôle quand même il faut pas il faut
pas sous-estimer ça
on va cramer qui fait il fait des
interviews il dit que
il aime pas
pour aller voir
on va diffuser un VL évidemment parce
que
mvl suis allé résa c'est très bien fait
d'abord les perdants ensuite les
gagnants
des trucs moi ce qui est bien c'est que
j'ai battu cramique dans un minimax
et la première partie on a fait nul
c'était ma tante pour lui
au moment où il fait nul c'est
maintenant 4 pour lui true story pour
aller voir sur le chascom
c'est quand même assez ça tombe bien
quoi du coup je peux pas être trop
soupçonné quand même fallait parce que
faut être un sacré confiance quand même
pour laisser un matin 4
qui était pas du tout introuvable bon
moi j'avais pas vu mais non plus on
avait plus de temps tous les deux mais
c'était quand même assez exceptionnel
alors pour G4 il met la pression sur ce
pion tourner un on va aller là
où là on sait pas
alors ça parle toujours là-bas
alors la fameuse
choupi c'était online c'était dans ce
même tournoi c'était en division 3 je
l'ai battu dans des tons impressionnants
et donc je l'ai battu je l'ai battu un
demi-heure et demi dans un minimat et
voilà après on a joué aussi dans un
playing on avait fait nul une partie où
il y avait des erreurs donc c'est assez
marrant quoi c'est assez cocasse de le
battre parce que dès qu'il perd
normalement il est il accuse la personne
d'avoir triché moi j'ai échappé à ces
bon je connais bien quand même on se
connaît bien analysé ensemble et c'est
très bien que je peux le battre la
preuve c'est que j'ai battu en 2013 en
partie longue mais
voilà bon je pense que de toute façon
quand on va travailler quelqu'un pendant
aussi longtemps je pense qu'il y a une
sorte de respect mutuel je l'espère en
tout cas je soupçonnerai pas moi non non
jamais
jamais alors B5 jouer par allez resa il
a protégé son pion laservic mais là il
met pas du tout le feu à la position il
arrive pas
il arrive pas à laservic là ça devrait
être nul cette finale et Yannick godzoli
qui avait gagné un petit peu comme ça en
mettant le roi en faisant passer le roi
assez loin en Coupe de France en finale
je crois
ouais j'ai aussi battu Magnus et
personne n'a mis le moindre soupçon
ouais effectivement j'ai battu j'ai
battu ma news où il a fini avec il a
quand même gagné le tournoi
et j'ai quand même fini en division 3
comme quoi c'était la rando ou trois
il a fait une j'ai fait une très bonne
partie et oui ça peut arriver et oui et
oui c'est pas interdit de bien jouer
et il a fait
une très mauvaise partie
pas très mauvaise mais j'ai bien j'ai
bien puni j'ai vu une belle j'ai fait
une belle partie franchement
ouais tout à fait cramique a battu
Kasparov après avoir été son second nom
donc cramique a battu Garric de Bakou en
2000 il avait été son secondaire pour le
match de 95
alors il pousse ses pions par là en même
temps
il gagne un peu d'espace il y a pas
grand chose à faire c'est pas si mal son
truc j'aime bien
il empêche des éventuels tours c'est un
tour C7 qui a un master tous les pions
et on va voir comment il va tenir cette
finale alors je suppose que F3 va venir
au roi F3 c'est ça la question et
ensuite on va la tour par là pour
essayer de menacer ton ses cinq
alors qu'est-ce qui joue sur W3 par
exemple
dont j'ai 8 je suppose mes tours C1
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
désagréable cette légère pression pour
les blancs
il faut chercher sur mes crâni qui se
plaint il se plaint allez voir son
profil il met plein de messages où il
accuse un peu tout le monde n'allait pas
voir en fait c'est pas intéressant
franchement c'est pas intéressant
après il a fait une vidéo sur une image
où il explique le pourquoi du comment
franchement
oui moi j'ai l'avantage en fait il y a
un gros avantage
que j'ai
en fait le fait d'être là depuis
longtemps
au niveau de plus longtemps fait qu'on
n'est pas
beaucoup moins soupçonnable pourquoi
parce que moi j'ai 2650 quand les
ordinateurs n'existaient pas mais en
fait ouais en fait qui jouait beaucoup
moins bien que nous
donc en fait ça prouve que on a un
niveau qui est déjà moi j'ai le même
hello bon j'ai été plus loin j'étais à
2700 mais j'ai le même élo il y a 20 ans
que maintenant vous pouvez regarder les
lots de de 2003 j'ai 2650
donc j'avais le même vélo donc ça en
fait finalement
ça surprend personne parce que c'était
une époque où on battait les ordinateurs
encore on battait les ordinateurs qu'on
avait sur nos sur nos portables donc on
pouvait pas donc la triche là vraiment
servait à rien parce que c'est des
ordinateurs qu'on
combattaient donc il y a beaucoup moins
ces histoires de triche et donc on avait
prouvé en quelque sorte son niveau donc
c'est vrai que les anciens entre
guillemets
qui ont commencé sans ordinateur et qui
ont été un gros niveau sans ordinateurs
sont pas du tout soupçonnés
c'était ça les rumeurs
moi j'ai entendu des rumeurs de joueurs
qui avaient des antisèches pour se
rappeler les ouvertures qui planquait
des trucs dans leur poche dans la
portefeuille avec des lignes de
des lignes écrites à la main voilà plein
de petits papiers avec les coups et tout
ça moi c'est ce que j'ai entendu c'était
le truc
ça ça bave assez beaucoup aussi à
l'époque ça c'est fini ce temps-là ça
bave assez énormément entre les joueurs
c'était un truc quasi quasi normal de
parler de sa partie
de parler de sa partie pendant la partie
j'étais très jeune à l'époque donc
je voyais des joueurs avec plus
d'expérience que moi qui faisait ça et
c'était un truc
assez accepté finalement c'est normal
qui a disparu et qui a disparu comme les
nuls à rangés ça a disparu aussi c'est
un truc complètement accepté qu'il est
plus
ou très rarement en tout cas
donc voilà l'état d'esprit a changé et
notamment grâce à Magnus clairement ce
qui fait jamais nul à ranger qui joue
toujours jusqu'au dernier pion
bon maintenant les ordis qui sont
arrivés donc effectivement c'est
complètement interdit de discuter
parce que là c'est
c'est notre genre de triche mais bon
sur quoi pendant les matchs il disait
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ma partie
d'abord
ouais moi j'ai eu plein de joueurs plein
de joueurs à le faire d'une génération
d'après ou c'était la génération qui
était
qui était plus âgé que moi à l'époque
qui qui faisait beaucoup ça honnêtement
impensable aujourd'hui ouais c'est ça
mais en fait c'était un truc
en fait tu allais discuter avec ton
copain
et l'autre il discutait avec son copain
voilà
et puis
100 minimiser le truc qui est absolument
anormal mais
c'était voilà c'était un truc plus pour
se rassurer en fait les joueurs qui
faisaient ça ils faisaient ça plus pour
se rassurer qu'autre chose
tout à fait ou à Stone c'est exactement
comme ça qu'il a il a perdu contre
diblue
plus âgé que moi ce n'est en 88 tout à
fait
tu imagines un exemple que tu penses de
ma copine
effectivement
alors qu'est-ce que ça donne cette
finale de tourbe elle est pas elle est
pas folle là pour l'instant ton serveur
il a fait roi des 6 évidemment ouais
c'est bien vu au roi des 6 et j'ai 4
maintenant il va essayer de peut-être
faire G5 et peut-être
si de s'organiser pour faire G5 et taper
ensuite sur ce pion h essayez de
combiner un peu tout ça mais c'est un
peu soft honnêtement
donc
on va voir
on va voir ce que va faire à l'IRISA qui
réfléchit qui prend pas mal de temps il
est pas évident cette position parce que
les finales de pion a tellement pas
envie de la jouer au final de pion
est-ce que est-ce qu'elle serait foutue
celle-là c'est un truc qui me
qui m'intrigue j'ai l'impression que oui
c'est de la même
ou après on va simplement faire ranger
trois F4
E5 ou G5 et se créer un pion passé elles
sont dangereux c'est final de pur faut
mieux pas tenter le diable avec les
noirs
comment on fait je triché un peu pour
voir comment il a gagné il fait roi F4
et si on voit 7 il fait G5 maintenant et
si on prend là il prend du roi
typiquement ça c'est intéressant et là
c'est zigzang complet si on fait rooi F8
on peut me faire wave 6 en est gagnant
là
dès qu'on va là admettons moi G8 H5 h65
est-ce que 5 gagne
même recette gagne 7 E5
moi j'ai 8 et roi des 6 et vas-y je
t'encaisse tous les pions donc attention
à ce genre de choses évidemment à lire
Elsa il est pas né de la dernière pluie
et donc il va il va comprendre tout ça
mais normalement ça irait je vais jeter
un petit coup d'œil sur la partie entre
notre ami
Aniche qu'est-ce qu'il en fait Aniche
est-ce qu'il s'en sort ou pas non c'est
pas les Winners c'est les losers
ils sont les loosers ils sont là et à
complètement gagnant avec les Blancs
contre
Ikaru Nakamura c'est une petite surprise
quand même de voir Nakamura probablement
out après simplement deux matchs et roi
F4 jouer G4 il a fait H6 Ali resa et sur
why F4 et bien il doit encore trouver
des coups c'est pas évident
non je crois pas qu'on puisse envoyer
alors ça c'est intéressant merci pour la
question Bixente je crois que c'est pas
bon parce que le problème c'est que ça
crée un pion passé donc on va pouvoir
mettre la tour derrière
tu reprends et Rouag G4 et ensuite on va
pousser par là et concrètement en fait
le problème de jouer à 5 c'est ça crée
une faiblesse certes et je comprends ton
idée et franchement c'est
c'est intéressant mais le vrai souci
c'est que ça crée c'est que ça crée un
pion passé
au
noir
et roi F4
ok A4
au blanc pardon au blanc ça craint un
pion passé à chaud blanc
je m'embrouille et je vous embrouille
peut-être échec peut-être F3 d'abord
échec et ensuite un coup de 5 pour
essayer d'activer le roi wifi F3 c'est
ça son plan c'est de faire échec de
décaler le roi et de faire le 5 mais
c'est vrai que finalement ce coup de
pion était intéressant parce qu'on va
avoir du contre-jour il fait tomber 8 OK
et surtout des un qu'est-ce qu'il veut
il veut roi E7 probablement et sur 5 pas
toucher
peut-être faire tourner quelque chose
comme ça pour essayer de s'activer par
là intéressant
on pourra les masques bon
ouais ça serait
c'est un peu compliqué techniquement
honnêtement là à ce moment-là du match
rien que pour kiffer les les grimaces du
carreaux
c'est beaucoup de soucis pour pour pas
grand chose parce qu'on les connaît les
grimaces du carreaux
et c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
aller résa de pas avoir de plus avoir
des carreaux dans le loser bracket et
d'avoir un niche qui est quand même
beaucoup plus abordable on va pas se
mentir
mais il faut se méfier évidemment
allez les grives ah oui c'est ça oui
tonton
il sait très bien ce que c'est de
changer les caméras sur un call zoom
et en plus de commentaire en même temps
[Musique]
on va se détendre quand même
on va se détendre sur ce coup-là
j'ai pas j'ai pas piné
c'est pas évident Tim c'est mieux ouais
ils sont sur zoom bon j'arrive à
épingler parce que j'ai host on parle
technique avec tonton excusez-moi je
parle technique avec ton temps c'est
entre expert on se comprend
donc
j'arrive à épingler les images mais j'en
avais plein donc faut que j'ai des
épingles les deux pour épingler les deux
autres
bon bref j'ai pas eu le temps envie de
faire ça maintenant
je le ferai évidemment pour mvl quand il
arrive
de toute façon les autres sont partis il
voit et oui on parle même langage
on a même pas
tourbé 8 OK et attends un peu donc du
coup ce truc avec 5 ça a foiré donc
maintenant
il va il va essayer de faire ça et de
créer quelque chose à l'aile dame
parce qu'en fait si l'échange c'est
depuis on compte c'est deux pions si
liquide Elda en quelque sorte c'est
archi nul facilement parce que le pion
doublé en fait il est très bon en
défense il empêche de faire G5 on va
simplement prendre donc tout est tout
est bon on est en rapide c'est du 15 + 3
c'est marqué en haut
c'est marqué en haut c'est les
demi-finales alors là c'est le bracket
c'est le loser bracket les demi-finale
c'est après
roi des 4 ok pourquoi pas
il essaie de tourner la zavik c'est vrai
que cette finale est un peu mieux pour
les blancs depuis le début mais bon ça
tient
c'est normalement pas le style resa mais
il faut savoir jouer dans tous les
styles
est-ce qu'on fait B4 ou pas c'est ça la
question qu'on va se poser à l'IRESA
non il fait tout à 8 ok donc là il a
clairement décidé d'attendre que la vie
montre son plan
peut-être ça qu'est-ce que vous voulez
faire d'autre
attention ton C5
ouais le Game price c'est quoi
c'est le
price archi connu
vous pouvez aller voir sur
Championship tour info vous avez tous
les prix
des trois divisions tout est archi
transparent
il y a aucun souci là-dessus pour aller
voir
ton
V8 bah oui
nous on est content avec la
ouais il va tenir je pense le Prince Ali
va tenir
à mon avis
je vois pas ce qui va se passer alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe chez Annie je
dirige je vais voir vite fait il est
toujours complètement gagnant Aniche et
il a besoin que de faire nul il va se
qualifier pour
continuer sa route dans le looser
bracket
alors comment on fait avec les Blancs et
bien c'est pas évident du tout je crois
qu'à un moment ou un autre on va être
obligé de faire ça alors faut choisir
les bonnes conditions pour faire ça
mais
quoi d'autre franchement il y a pas
d'autres percée
laser cherche
on va voir déjà si on est en vrai direct
là pour les coups
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
salut Fontenoy 56
ouais ouais bien sûr bien sûr la zavik
déjà rien que d'être là dans cette
division 1 c'est quand même assez
magnifique dans le dernier champion il
s'est quand même très très bien
débrouillé
là c'est plus dur mais bon il joue ma
médié en filière il joue à aujourd'hui
c'est quand même pas évident
clairement ok pour ces trois bon
ok ok
donc on va avoir du Tour à 8
il veut vraiment le pousser à jouer
bécane sur B4 il veut faire ça et dire
ouais
c'est ça l'idée je vois pas d'autres
idées franchement
alors time control chez le prince tout à
fait 2 minutes d'avance chez alia
zafiruza qui a 3 38 contre une 25 et qui
en contrôle dans cette partie roi il va
tenter quelque chose à sa vie ou pas il
en vient de trois on voit pas trop son
plan là depuis le début
mais lui non plus d'ailleurs
alors comment on fait maintenant
tomber 8 au hasard
il veut encore à mon avis faire Wave 4
et tour des trois échecs et E5 je pense
que c'est vraiment le seul plan il y a
pas d'autres plans que je veux 5
clairement parce que si on fait roi F4
et G5 tout va se liquider il y aura rien
du tout pour les blancs
donc le seul plan un peu constructif
c'est de faire ça
et réfléchis et réfléchir notre ami à
mais franchement je sais pas qu'est-ce
qu'il attend il joue tombé 8 tours à
huit depuis 5 6 ou 7 coups
peut-être quelque chose de plus de plus
concret de plus rapide
de plus incisif
et tombez vite joué de 23 contre une 22
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire les avis
évidemment que tomber 8 a été joué F4 et
oui il devait faire quelque chose alors
peut-être il veut tourner 3 et 5 au
final il a changé d'avis il a changé son
fusil d'épaule c'est officiel Aniche 2
Ikaru zéro et oui une surprise
clairement
Annie qui continue son parcours dans ce
tournoi il avait perdu hier de manière
assez sèche face à Yann les pommiers
mais là il continue on va faire un petit
tour du côté du bracket
rapidement après ça
bref tour B8 et maintenant
comment on fait
il faut un moment faire échec à mon avis
faire E5 le plan c'est ça globalement
si je laisse faire un mettons les noirs
si on laisse faire voilà le plan ça va
être ça et de faire G5 et de se créer un
purge mais même ça vous voyez j'ai rien
fait penser coup ça a rien fait
donc qu'est-ce qu'il a fait laservic il
a fait H5 tour G8 il va empêcher ça
tourne ces deux
maintenant il dit c'est à toi de jouer
VL tu n'as rien
raté mvl sera après ce match là
donc tu n'as rien raté du côté de mvl 4
parties face à créer un média Rohff
il a un très gros score contre ma médias
je sais pas un des deux entre non je
crois que c'est lui qui a un gros score
est-ce que les paris d'argent sont
autorisés aux échecs
rkpmn sur Youtube qui demande ça pas en
France dans d'autres pays oui
pas encore en France c'est ton jamais
pour revenir
après c'est un petit marché
ton G8 prono Fraisse vous ferez les
pronos chaque semaine
voilà vous me suivez vous me suivez pas
après
ce qui veulent gagner vont me suivre
ceux qui veulent perdre vont pas suivre
ok donc il attend qu'il bouge sa tour
clairement pour juger 5
ouais à ma mère a pas été grandiose en
plus hein il a fait 4000 contre la zavik
donc je pense que Maxime sans être
chauvin il est gros favori quand il
m'avait dit
oui oui ça c'est vrai que
au Royaume-Uni on peut parler sur à peu
près tout et n'importe quoi il y a
toujours un bookmaker pour faire une
cote et effectivement ça se passe
surtout au Royaume-Uni les paris sur les
échecs
bon je sais que mes pas mes trucs
étaient cotés mais parti était coté
parfois sur Unibet je crois ouh là
sur un site de paris en ligne
je dis des bêtises
on n'a pas le droit de parler de ça je
sais pas
j'ai pas fait exprès en tout cas
bip ouais c'est ça il a fait B4
finalement après on met trop à prendre
mes trois et maintenant il va faire et
empêcher il empêcher 5 en contrôlant le
pion h
tour à 8 tours à trois certainement
on va contre attaquer
et il veut faire tomber 4 pour pacifier
la tour et peut-être éventuellement
passer avec l'euro à essayer de faire G5
ça va être ça le plan
quoi d'autre
ah mais moi j'ai jamais parié
c'est illégal en France de parier sur ça
donc moi je fais pas les choses légales
c'est gentil Ziggy 22 ou alors si je
fais une chose illégale je dis pas
en direct filmé
grosse révélation aujourd'hui j'ai déjà
fait
une chose illégale dans ma vie
plus qu'une certaine main
pas bien
des coups déjà pour commencer
c'est chaud quand même là je parle je
parle on rigole on rigole puis on prend
un tour des cinq à Tours c'est trop
échec là oui on contre-attaque
évidemment roi des deux tours en V3 ça
ça va être nul facile ce 3 contre 3 il
est archi nul et laservic décidément qui
a pas réussi du tout à
à poser des problèmes à les raisins on
va aller la même si on perce le pion
c'est nul alors imaginez avec ce pion
les noirs sont mieux tout simplement on
va faire tourger trois prochains coups
j'ai 5 on va prendre où on va faire on
fait ce qu'on veut on peut pousser aussi
on peut faire à peu près ce qu'on veut
aucune chance de perdre
tout ça certainement roi G7 pour pas
être coupé
peut-être à 6 à là on va faire tout
droit tout simplement
et ensuite B4 B3 non mais il va échanger
les avis je crois qu'il va échanger tour
prends mes cinq tours prend le 4 et
ouais ça va faire nul
ça va faire nul
et on voit
ça y est
nul entre la zavik et alias voyons on
l'a eu en direct ou la zavik il est
parti illuminé et allez ça donc il
emporte avec sur ce score
de 1 et demi
à
traîner là
à 0 et demi
bravo
alors
mais c'est quand j'étais jeune ça qui
Brown
franchement qui n'a jamais fait
alors on va regarder le bracket et vous
voyez donc fil rouge
allez-y
qui va pas jouer contre
le perdant à mon avis de Carlson dépôt
qui va être reversé dans le loser
bracket donc Nakamura et lasavik c'est
terminé pour eux c'est fini ils sont
éliminés ils ont la prochaine fois
ensuite je pense que guéri jouera le
perdant de Vachier La Grave ma médias
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
Maxime ça même si hyper il a il a guéri
derrière donc ça c'est bon
on va voir
on va voir ce que ça va donner on va
voir ça aussi à quelle heure il joue
c'est là c'est ça ou c'est ça qu'on sait
pas
à quelle heure joue mvl on va voir tout
ça je vais essayer de choper l'info du
coup
je suis pas sûr du tout
il va certainement nous répondre
ou pas on sait pas
donc il est 19h33 là alors je vous parle
et il y a un VL qui arrive même arrive à
quelle heure c'est ça la question c'est
prévu à 19h50
mais est-ce que ils vont pas avancer le
match
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien j'attends
les news on va faire les infos
déjà on va voir est-ce que
je vais enlever le truc de zoom je vais
voir s'ils sont dans le sinon dans le
col on va envoyer le premier et le
deuxième
et je vais aller voir de ce
pas alors je vais supprimer les pingles
ouais
[Musique]
pour l'instant
alors on va cadrer déjà on va faire ça
on va épingler
c'est bien ça il arrive alors notre avis
on va vous le montrer
et en plus je vais vous faire une petite
et on va
épingler
notre ami et regarder sous vos yeux
ébahis
regardez ça c'est de la technique en
direct
bon il ressemble pas trop à lire et
mais voilà on va avoir mvl et vous avez
secrète là
Maxime machin grave qui a un siège
secrète Lab qui est notre sponsor du
tournoi avec RCS
vous voyez donc on a on a on a ces deux
sponsors il a reçu une chaise que j'ai
pas reçu moi j'aimerais bien secretlab
je vous fais de la pub envoyez-moi une
chaise alors on va
mettre MV ici
pas beau ça mvl et on va changer le nom
la bas de ma média off
ça va être on va commencer à 0
parce que sinon
c'est quand même pas vraiment équitable
et il y a un changement
il y a un changement c'est plus le
premier à un demi c'est le premier à
2 et demi donc on va faire ça je vais le
changer là de mes finales
[Musique]
à 2,5 et normalement ça devrait
apparaître sous vos yeux
j'espère que vous êtes ébahis
et voilà gain du match à 2,5
j'espère donc on a Maxime qui est là on
a la média qui est là
ils ont pas l'air d'être en train de
commencer là honnêtement
mais il faut rester pour voir tout ça
et pour voir ce match au meilleur des
quatre parties est-ce qu'on aura quatre
parties ou pas est-ce que Maxime
on va faire ça aussi
est-ce que Maxime commence avec les
blancs avec les Noirs c'est ça la grande
question
et on sait pas
normalement le premier cité a toujours
les blancs
le premier site a toujours les blancs
dans la première
donc Maxime aura les blancs dans la
première
contre chaque criarde donc on sait déjà
que Maxime aura donc les blancs bah oui
mais entourage qui après ouais ok donc
on sait pas ouais donc effectivement la
nouvelle du jour
en tout cas la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'elle a gagné son match et donc
il revient dans ce tournoi
en tout cas il est pas éliminé toujours
en course notre ami airesa y jouera le
perdant du match Carlsen des premiers à
chi on préfère que ça soit une époque
quand même
et donc
on a Maxime va chez Lagrave qui va en
découdre dans cette demi-finale de la
a I Cup artificiel intelligence SCOP et
bien on aura Maxime
dans quelques petites minutes restées
avec moi je pense que ça devrait
commencer bientôt je vais vous mettre
une petite pub en attendant quand même
ça vous manquait moi je pense
voilà petite pub et je suis de retour à
tout de suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title
tussday.com/avent tous les plus grands
tournois d'échecs qui se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent aussi
bien sur le site internet que sur nos
applications iOS et Android pour vivre
votre passion comme nulle part ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour
pour cette
deuxième partie de soirée qui s'annonce
palpitante avec un match de Maxime
agrafe à Sacha mvl
dans ce match c'est les demi-finales de
la hay Cup et on a eu déjà une victoire
danielafiruja face aux jeunes de Nice
lazavik qui lui permet de continuer
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs j'ai fait n'importe quoi
mais on revient
qui lui permet de revenir dans le
tournoi
en fait de continuer dans le tournoi
dans ce loser bracket vous le voyez en
bas tout en bas il résa il jouera le
perdant
de Carsen et pomyachi
et
tandis Queen jouera le perdant de Vacher
La Grave et de vainqueurs sont en
comptant en demi-finale comme quoi c'est
pas si dur que ça à suivre on a un match
qui va très certainement
bientôt commencer
voilà il est perdu il est parti Maxime
ah non il est là Maxime on l'a en bas et
on va avoir bientôt la partie c'est ma
news d'abord je pense
Magnus d'abord
ok donc on va regarder quand même le
début de Magnus sans les caméras Magnus
Carlsen allez blanc face à il y a des
pommiers on a une pétrole et dans deux
minutes on aura le début de Maxime va
chez Lagrave face à chaque rameau vous
allez on peut les mettre même les mettre
à l'écran non ça va être là plutôt
et on comprendra quand c'est quand
est-ce qu'ils vont commencer au body
language
dame 7 c'est des trois KFC 3 ok c'est
très très solide de la part de Magnus
qui joue des positions simples contre
Yann et pomyachi et il avait battu au
speedchais en faisant ce genre de
d'ouverture et donc voilà bah il se il
fait comme d'habitude
petit avantage petite finale peut-être
la petite finale et ensuite normalement
il fait pareil sa technique alors
ouais il a du mal quand même ces
derniers temps il y a des pommiers à
chier depuis le match champion du monde
c'est compliqué pour lui face à ma
muscarsen
clairement
mais on va voir normalement il a dû
préparer ça peut-être qu'ils se souvient
pas très bien parce qu'il sait jamais
hein Magnus peut jouer au 4 peut jouer
des 4 il peut pas tout jouer Magnus
Carlsen donc c'est jamais évident de
réviser la bonne ligne et il décide de
prendre un autre jeu de 7 et il y a
d'autant plus il y a ceux cavalier C3
qui a été qui en plus et en plus c'est
au blanc de jouer donc
légère avantage développement évidemment
pas de faiblesse du côté noir donc ça
reste quand même très très solide
et normalement ça donne rien du tout
pour les pour les blancs mais bon c'est
Magnus quand même donc il fait il sait
normalement à peu près ce qu'il fait on
n'est pas trop inquiet pour lui
et on va très certainement bientôt
basculer sur la partie de Maxime Vacher
la grave
qui on l'espère j'aurai de manière un
peu plus agressive avec les Blancs ouais
grand on va faire tout racheur ensuite
petit avantage blanc
rien de dingue clairement
mais pas évident pour les Noirs
peut-être c'est 6 dessins pour essayer
de stabiliser tout ça et d'avoir une
structure plus solide
mvl je joue principalement E4 quasi
quoique c'est un étang il a fait
d'autres choses
on va voir si les deux joueurs ont
repris
je pense qu'on est pas loin parce que
normalement il y a 2 minutes de décalage
de décalage donc on va aller voir ça
tout de suite
on a qu'une partie pour l'instant ok bon
est-ce que
j'ai des nouveaux ouais deux minutes
normalement
2 minutes
ça aurait du commencer la partie de
Maxime mais ça n'a pas encore commencé
parfois il y a toujours un petit même
les joueurs mais on voit qu'ils sont
concentrés là
et ça a commencé chez Maxime va chez
Lagrave on va aller aussi récupérer la
partie en live que vous puissiez suivre
puis c'est suivre la partie en live
on va voir chez Maxime ce que ça donne
et donc c'est une Espagnole normalement
il est plutôt adepte de l'espagnol
ouvert
cette tour hein mais cinq fouets 3D 6c3
recash 3 sa position principale de
l'espagnol ici il y a beaucoup d'options
cahier des cèdes cavaliers 5 fubé 7
azzaït-sep tour 8 même à 5 et un coup et
encore un autre vous aussi qui vient
d'être joué par chaque Rea une petite
sous variante
pas de Gambie Marshall fou B3 le grand
Marshall on va le montrer c'est sur
petit rock directement qui
les Blancs jouent à 4 en général maxime
est un adepte du coup à 4 ici et sur ces
trois D5 et on donne un pion pour un jeu
de pièces
plus actif avec les noirs on va jouer
fouder 6 on va jouer tour 8 on va jouer
d'un match 4 on va jouer fou F5 il y a
beaucoup de jeux
mais chaque client j'aime jouer
énormément donc c'est vraiment pas c'est
vraiment pas son truc
alors ici de prendre des doubles pions
ok il est pas pris mauve puis on prend
aussi ça crée un il s'y attendait pas
et des 4 OK et on prend le centre bah
écoutez
tout à fait tout à fait normal ce qui
fait Maxime l'inconvénient
pour les noirs de prendre un des quatre
si ça ça donne la
case naturelle du cavalier en C3
même G6 toujours très agressif rien
mais qui a tout à fait le style pour se
faire contrer
par la précision tactique de mvl
qui j'aime bien j'aime bien comment il
joue ces derniers temps il prend son
temps
très concentré même online il donne le
meilleur de lui-même
alors dame 8 comment on fait maintenant
est-ce qu'on va développer comme ça
ou d'abord le fou c'est une question on
peut prendre aussi ici mais bon
pas sûr ça va être vraiment les blancs
parce qu'ensuite on mettrait le fond
c'est 5 et il décide de faire fouger 5
pourquoi pas et ensuite sortir son
cavalier en deux
intéressant bon c'est clairement pas une
réputation mais ça joue
ça joue c'est ce qu'il aime Maxime quand
ça joue comme ça
alors maintenant dames 8 clairement
l'idée c'était de venir avec la dame par
là une des deux cases
on va voir
on va voir ce qu'il va faire
intéressant
je sais pas dame G6 alors normal qui est
BD2
mais on n'a pas embêté on aimerait venir
par là peut-être qu'on peut le faire
j'en sais rien
attention à cavalier F4 qui peut arriver
pas mal de jeux ça ça serait pas très
bon pour les blancs déjà
donc les choses comme ça a l'air très
logique pour les Noirs après on peut
envisager aussi cavalier 5 directement
il faut calculer un petit peu mais ouais
c'est vrai que la case F4 quand même
très tentant pour ce cavalier
donc on peut jouer food 3 revenir
et on dit qu'on a mis ce cavalier sur
une webcam
mais ça fait une petite perte de temps
il joue à 6 et il dit ok choisis ton
camp ici ou ici
ou ici donne-moi ton fou
H6 très logique
il faut 3 à mon avis c'est pas possible
à cause de caille prend le 4 des 5
encore on peut pas prendre il y a dame
prend et on ramasse le cavalier mes
cavaliers des 8 par exemple
et c'est clair que ce pion va être pris
tôt ou tard ça ne va pas aller
donc H6
et maintenant
comment on fait
s'il faut H4 vous voyez ça libère
clairement la case F4 pour le cavalier
on peut plus l'empêcher donc c'est un
petit ouais c'est un petit problème pour
les blancs ici c'est une vraie question
vous prend vous prend
ça pas été joué il a joué H4 pardon
OK
comme vous pouvez le voir en bas je
rappelle en bas vous avez le chéquier
life
fois je suppose que il a pas voulu
donner son fou c'est logique parce
qu'après on mettait la pression sur des
4 c'était pas terrible ça avait pas
l'air terrible il faut acheter très
logique maintenant cavalier H5 est
vraiment le coup qu'on a envie de jouer
si ça marche tactiquement donc si ça
marche statiquement c'est ça la question
ok prends le 5
parce qu'on a ce rayon X
mais on récupère comme ça
et les Noirs ont l'air pas mal pas de
problème d'ouverture au minimum d'un
meuf 6 va arriver
on peut pas vraiment en prendre là parce
que le cavalier serait trop bien placé
donc faut H4 il réfléchit agréable mais
cavalh5 a priori il va arriver
c'est quelque chose comme ça
j'ai trois mais bon
voyez on attaque ici qui est BD2 a pas
l'air possible à cause depuis on prend
des quatre puis on prend attention les
petits pièges un déjà pour les blancs ça
ça serait mat
donc ça n'irait pas
rappel la cadence 15 plus 3 donc c'est
assez on a du temps mais pas tellement
non plus
il faut quand même garder un rythme
élevé
et un fichier à G5 non non mais non
chaque rien pas tout de suite quand même
faut attendre un peu
je sais pas ça me semble quand même
délicat de commencer tambour battant et
que j'ai 5
ouais c'était viable d'échanger ce même
comme ça c'est parfois viable avec les
noirs avec les Blancs
même comme ça bon là ça a pas l'air
extraordinaire parce que on s'est créé
on a créé une majorité au centre pour
les noirs
on peut jouer ça par exemple pour
essayer de faire pression là dessus
mais par exemple sur
admettons le cas hypothétique ouais ce
genre de truc c'est viable pour les
blancs ça c'est sûr
c'est pas un désastre de donner ce fou
de Cat noir
gus gus gus gus
donc ok ok ok ok ok
et réfléchis beaucoup je trouve hein
je sais pas comment il fait je sais pas
quel est l'option en fait il me semble
tellement naturel
que
venir là plus tard
je sais pas c'est la moins fort quand
même
je sais pas même
rien que les noirs
ce week et bienvenue pour ce match
cette demi-finale de la High Cup
artificial intelligence Cup
entre
Maxime et
qui prend beaucoup de temps là qui prend
3 minutes de retard
je sais pas quoi y réfléchir honnêtement
ça me paraît très étrange ce qu'il fait
à prendre d'abord mais ça donne le
centre c'est ça c'est pas bon ça c'est
pas bon on n'est pas content et puis ça
donne des tours c'est un aussi ce
cavalier va être en l'air souvent
pas terrible
c'est plutôt bon pour nous si réfléchit
et jugez 5 oh là là là là là là là là là
sacré sacréas et bien
et bien
ouais tu vois je te montre ma chemise
soit
une chemise saumonée
bon pourquoi pas
alors Maxime il réfléchit pas à
sacrifier ça c'est sûr que ça marche pas
il réfléchit à prendre d'abord un 5
qui peut être intéressant non full G3
logique G5 franchement c'est tout moche
c'est tout molle j'ai 5 ça y est alors
que cavalier H5 donner une position safe
à Leroy les pions ne reculent pas
mais c'est typique sacré à je vous
l'avais dit il est très chaud chaque
criait en général il envoie tout
et aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il y a quand même il
donne une sacrée température au match on
sent que sans qu'il va foncer ouais non
c'est trop risqué j'ai 5 objectifs c'est
pas bon
cavalier H5 et maintenant faut H2 je
suppose
ouais ok prends j'ai trois comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure on a pas envie
de le laisser faire
donc je suppose 2
mais c'est pas
c'est pas sûr on peut jouer avec aussi
on peut commencer par prendre ici quoi
que ça ouvrira pas mal
la chose le jeu
on peut jouer des dessins aussi
on peut jouer des 5 comme ça sur surpuis
on prend
quoi que quoi puis on prend moins on est
à la case 4 pour le cavalier ça peut
être pas si mal
donc
et cavalier H5 a été joué par chacun il
joue à 4 alors là j'avoue on l'a pas vu
venir celui-là ok il essaie de divertir
clairement chaque créa et de menacer de
faire pu en prendre peut-être des
échanges ici peut-être un coup de
cavalier à 3 qui va attaquer le pion B5
de créer quelque chose un peu de jeu de
l'autre côté de chez qui pourquoi pas
on va voir
ce qui fait notre ami notre ami sa créa
peut-être
qu'il y a quand même on a envie de se
prendre de prendre de prendre le fou en
G3 et de jouer peut-être un coup comme
fouf si je sais pas
je voulais 6
pourquoi pas et mets de la pression
peut-être des 5 vous me direz
intéressant
D5 alors à 4 qui est rangé 3 F point G 3
fois est-ce qu'on prend la dame ou
est-ce qu'on prend du ouais c'est
toujours la question est-ce qu'on prend
du pion de la dame
ça fait chèque mais tout est protégé
quand même pour les ah quoi que tout
n'est plus protégé
il manque quand même un pion à la fin de
l'histoire ça c'est pas terrible
ils sont actif c'est vrai à 4 il fait
puis on prend un 4 alors là je vous
l'avais dit hier chaque heure le
problème c'est que je devine pas un coup
c'est quand même assez hallucinant quoi
j'ai 5 et après puis on prend un 4 qui
est quand même un coup abominable
stratégiquement
clairement ça va pas alors sur dame
prend A4 là je vous le dis tout de suite
il fait ça il y a pas de bluff ça fait
fil à caloche et après il s'organise
pour essayer de créer du jeu ça peut
être très bien marché d'ailleurs
mais c'est ça l'idée de divertir de
divertir les blancs peut-être tu
reprends alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur ton point c'est quoi son idée
j'ai absolument j'ai absolument pas du
tout la ref
je comprends pas du tout l'idée
parce que après on met 5 était une
menace certes mais pas une si grosse
menace
donc ça ça paraît étrange
quand même de prendre une décision aussi
radicale
qui me voilà le problème c'est que après
on peut plus jouer de finale parce qu'on
va être mal
à cause des de la faiblesse ici
donc ça remet en cause pas mal de choses
quand même
ça crée une faiblesse tout simplement
ouais
maxime a dû être surpris par ce coup
clairement
voir comment il va réagir on peut
intercaler des dessins peut-être
cette fois je te donne maintenant aussi
et c'est vrai que c'est actif G4 des 5 a
été joué
et il décide de
ouais de clarifier les choses au centre
c'est pas plus mal le fou viendra jamais
en C5 comme ça
ce fou sera toujours derrière sa
structure de pion
donc ça a pas forcément être évident
a priori il faut prendre
et là j'aime bien ah non cahier des huit
a été joué oui je trouve pas un coup là
normalement je trouve des coups mais
avec chaque criard jamais dame prend un
ok guide d'après la jauge est une faute
c'est vrai que puis on prend aussi ça
avait l'air quand même pas
bon je vais tricher
c'est tout reprends à 4 le coup alors
pourquoi tu reprends un 4 et meilleur
que me prend j'en sais rien
tu reprends à 4 était le meilleur coup à
l'idée de jouer C4 et C3 mais d'un point
4 peut pas être vraiment mauvais
honnêtement petite finale comme je vous
l'avais dit on joue la finale avec les
Blancs on est content avec ce pion là ça
n'irait pas du tout
et 3 minutes de moins pour chaque il y
avait complètement
complètement égalisé après l'ouverture
il suffisait de jouer cavalier H5 G5 et
c'était vraiment
très simple pour les noirs
et il a décidé de faire un coup assez
incroyable ce coup de G5 et maintenant
il décide de jouer la finale alors là je
vais vous dire que c'est égal moi je
trouve pas ça égale du tout
potentiellement on va avoir des soucis
sur ce pion
attention on peut être foutu en deux
coups on a deux coups d'être foutu alors
même si c'est égal d'après l'ordi ça
veut dire que
potentiellement il y a plus de coup
précis à jouer pour les Noirs c'est ça
le souci en fait
et
je vois pas comment on égalise peut-être
C6 à un moment pour essayer de quand
même très embêtant ce pion il domine
complètement ce cavalier en D8
donc c'est 6 pour réparer pas mal mais
ces quatre
tombez vite l'inconvénient c'est qu'on
va simplement jouer B4 encaissant ça
n'irait pas
il a joué qui est B7 et Ben et je vous
dis d'une manière très concrète il veut
faire que ces cinq cahiers des trois et
sur B4
qui normalement l'antidote en espagnol
quand le cavalier en B7 pensait toujours
à faire B4 parce qu'on contrôle les deux
cases mais la B4 je suppose qu'il veut
jouer à 5 il y a pas d'autre cours parce
que si on laisse faire les blancs encore
une fois on est à deux coups d'être
foutu donc ça n'irait pas donc là on
fait à 5 et on se libère vous voyez en
échange ce pion qui était tellement
faible donc c'est encore un jeu archi
concret de la part de chaque Ryan
c'est comme ça qui joue
écoutez ça marche pas mal pour lui quand
même globalement donc pourquoi pas
comment on fait ici parce que BD2 oui ok
j'allais en parler qui est assez simple
maintenant
et 3 mais à ce moment-là on peut faire
tout
à 5 et des trois mais tomber en
finalement c'est pas grand-chose et B4
et ensuite
et prend fou
on va reprendre une belle bloca dans le
4 donc c'est pas si grave et ce fou est
quand même pas terrible
on voit la structure certains
l'appellerait le mauvais fou
on va pas faire ça non
mais
[Musique]
là ça se tient là pour le coup ce
concept du mauvais fou
qui est c'est 5 jours et très rapidement
par chaque réa westelliaire de Key B7
donc là on va aller en Détroit je
pensais à tour à deux mais le tour à
deux il y a peut-être à 5 à 4 qui me
gêne un peu
et ça fait quand même du jeu on a
empêché B4 surtout un on peut même faire
tomber vite à mon avis à quatre et pas
bon à cause de B4 puis on prend en
passant on fait tour reprend donc ça
n'irait pas mais on peut faire tomber 8
et voilà l'avantage d'avoir joué à 5
c'est qu'on a plus ce coup b2b4
et je tourne à 5 mvl la vente qu'on
avait vu tout à l'heure et sur cahier
des trois il veut clairement faire
tourner d'abord et ensuite B4 kb7 jouer
waouh proposition tacite de nul mais je
pense ça va être refusé
il va jouer un coup de tour à deux je le
connais Maxime
tu auras deux
il a 4 minutes 3 minutes de plus et
franchement potentiellement une très
très bonne position je tourne à trois ok
bon
excusez-moi pour le les erreurs mais ça
change pas grand chose il va jouer tout
à l'heure au prochain coup il va menacer
et en vrai je vois pas trop comment les
Noirs s'en sortent
et attention si on fait une bloque ici
ça peut être sympa comme le cavalier B7
on va voir Magnus complètement gagnant
et oui Magnus les petites finales ça le
connaît
et on se rapproche peut-être alors c'est
que la première partie mais une belle
finale là demain ça serait dès demain
une filiale du braquet des des
vainqueurs donc ça serait pas la finale
absolue mais en tout cas ce serait une
belle finale du braquet des vainqueurs
avec un mvl Magnus Carlsen de gala
ça serait quand même sympa d'avoir ça
et comment on fait
cavalier 4 voilà cavalier F6 ah on prend
et on va en mettre une couche croyez-moi
il va en mettre une couche Maxime Vacher
La Grave oui cavalier F6 on aurait voulu
on aurait voulu ne pas prendre
évidemment mettre le cavalier ici mais
il y a qu'à prendre des 5 donc il y a un
problème tactique donc il prend
et maintenant qui est des deux
pour remettre le petit frère
en 4
intéressant
ouh là
en cas de Magnus contre
MVS pour qui
toujours cornélien
faire haïr
mais en tout cas je serai je suis pour
ce match voilà je suis pour ce match et
lieu
ça c'est certain
et suspends un beau match parce que bon
là c'est c'est quand même c'est pas un
match champion du monde non plus donc
voilà un beau match et je suis sûr que
Maxime dans le
dans la forme dans laquelle il est c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être
[Musique]
Manu ça dit il avait pas de rival hier
il y avait pas de rival Nakamura pas de
rival il est et les autres
mais peut-être qu'en ce moment c'est CMV
son principal
celui qui peut vraiment lui poser des
problèmes vu la vu la forme qu'il a
même si évidemment historiquement
Magnus gagne globalement alors il y a un
très gros score en particulier contre
contre Magnus contre Maxime Manu je
crois mène 9 à 2 ou un truc comme ça
peut-être plus même
donc et en match de partir rapide il
gagne aussi la plupart du temps donc
Magnus gros favori comme toujours
et il décide de faire cailler des oeufs
5 et cavalier ok d'échanger ses
cavaliers alors c'est pas exactement ce
qu'on voulait mais c'est pas mal on se
fout qui est pas terrible il joue le
dynamisme à tout prix chaque criard il a
bien raison parce que avec son fou il
peut se retrouver très mal alors là on
pose une question à ce pion est-ce qu'on
va faire B3 et oui on va faire B3 on va
jouer C4 on va essayer de faire F3 on va
essayer de faire fout et je vais quand
on se fout de casse noire qui est
complètement emmuré derrière ses pions
mais il va jouer de manière dynamique
chaque riz arrive à jouer de tour B4 et
à 4 certainement
et comment on fait ici certainement F3
pour faire fout
c'est vrai que dernièrement mvl est bien
je suis bien bien chaud c'est grâce au
coaching de Laurent Blanc
après ici
ces quatre tours B4 F3 pourquoi il fait
pas F3 là il faut
je crois que c'est la seule chance donc
chaque criards sont son but c'est au
moins alors il va rester avec ce fou
certes mais c'est au moins d'échanger
ses pions c'est ça l'idée mais c'est
vrai visuellement ça a l'air très bien
pour les blancs voilà jauge pas d'accord
4 30 4,50 mais c'est clair qu'il y a pas
de risque pour les blancs ça c'est ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle il va je vois
pas trop ce qu'il peut faire apparaître
honnêtement
je vois pas l'option
ramenez le la tour peut-être mais non
parce qu'il y a de tomber vite qui
arrive coucou à 5
peut-être pour eux
et comme ça sur A4 on a tout à deux
qui est toujours pas clair d'ailleurs
d'après la jauge
tour à 4 est mauvais il faut échanger 4
tours sinon c'est nul docteur big bass
j'ai pas compris
il faut échanger toutes les tours
tour à 4 est mauvais je crois je crois
qu'on est pas atteint alors c'est une
très bonne idée sur un plan purement
professionnel mais on n'est pas à temps
pour empêcher de tomber 4
si on échange toutes les tours moi je
serais pas rassuré avec les Noirs fiole
de fou honnêtement je trouve que c'est
chaud
je sais pas si ça serait nul mais avec
le roi qui peut éventuellement se frayer
un passage sur casse blanche le foot qui
peut combiner ça en venant par là
chatouiller les pions là mais joue F3
Maxime va chez Lagrave 3 12
il réfléchissez avec tous deux c'est
clair il hésitait on prend puis on prend
et maintenant
et maintenant le problème c'est que
cette tour est paralysé il fait H4 ouh
là c'est dommage de faire et puis on
prend maintenant
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait ça oui c'est
vrai qu'il y a un problème concret de
comment on fait pour activer cette tour
cette tour est beaucoup plus active que
cette tour pourquoi parce que cette tour
attaque en C4 et cette tour défense et 4
donc il y a un problème d'activité et
après le problème dash 4 déjà il peut
laisser
et en plus s'il prend la finale de tour
on n'y croit pas on n'y croit pas une
seule seconde que les blancs soient
mieux ici
donc là il met un coup de frein Maxime
il joue pour la nul
c'est ça que tu voulais dire d'accord
mais ouais effectivement on a même pas
ce qu'elle a ouais là c'est complètement
nul les blancs sont pas du tout mur en
fait
il y a une petite faiblesse mais en fait
c'est compensé par l'activité de cette
tour
ça va être gênant même si on vient avec
le roi par là la tour va contre-attaquer
par derrière sur les pions on a le droit
et j'ouvre H2 certainement faire wage 5
pour essayer d'améliorer notre situation
à l'aile roi
voilà on peut faire C6 aussi pour
essayer de liquider des pions et voilà
c'est 7 halte là je récupère et ça fait
un pion de moins et c'est si c'est joué
par chaque criard premier coup de la
partie que je devine il yes
ça vient
ça fait plaisir
manus en train de faire le roi volant
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on bascule pas
sur la partie de manuscrite
je vous laisse en live la partie de
Maxime et ça va faire nul c'est sûr
on va aller on va basculer rapidement
sur la partie de manus cardsen est-ce
qu'elle est plus marrante celle-là
une petite finale
petite finale de Magnus
pendant qu'on a le direct là direct
et vous voyez les deux joueurs mais
clairement il va pas se passer grand
chose ici on a Magnus Carlsen face est
nul nul signé entre
entre chaque rya et Maxime Vacher
Lagrave et on va tout de suite passer à
la partie de Magnus Carlsen avec les
Blancs contre eux Yann et paumes yashi
et il a une fille avec un pion de plus
mais franchement elle doit être nulle
celle-là parce que là on a vraiment le
vrai mauvais four le vrai fou pas
terrible quoi
et sur G4 le problème c'est qu'on pourra
jamais passer on va faire puis on prend
puis on prend revenir en G6 et on va
jamais passer
ouais c'est ça
un coup de vie sur 40 c'est vrai j'avais
parti de chaque criard moi je jouerai
contre moi si je dois faire des paris
c'est vrai que je jouerai pas la partie
de chaque air
effectivement non il y a aucune chance
là je pense de gagner parce que dès
qu'on fait ça par exemple
ici je sais pas et c'est vrai qu'on va
on va titiller ici donc même si je fais
ça
ça j'attends admettons hop ça ça
on va jamais réussir à passer on va
toujours empêcher
donc je vois pas voilà bon c'est la
partie pour l'instant
puis on prend puis on prend on voit 6
mais bon
ça donne rien
ah il va essayer de faire roi des trois
et ces quatre attention on n'enterre pas
ma muscle comme ça
architeau
[Musique]
aux échecs sont rentables pour les
bookmakers il y a quand même beaucoup de
nuls en fait tu es gentil les bookmakers
ils arrivent toujours à faire un truc en
pour eux t'inquiète pas pour eux
pour les joueurs comme pour les
bookmakers
je crois hein t'inquiéter pour les
bookmaker t'inquiète pas ils vont pas
faire les sites de paris en ligne ils
vont pas faire faillite à cause des
échecs je crois pouvoir être assez
affirmatif sur ça
et les poméashi qui est en train de
tenir sa finale alors c'est pas glorieux
effectivement pour Yann mais ça tient il
va faire ces quatre donc il va essayer
d'organiser ces quatre il peut pas pour
l'instant le pion B4 est en prise
il fait fout des deux et protège il veut
faire ses quatre mais ces quatre
évidemment qu'on va pas toucher avec les
Noirs malheureusement
c'est quatre on attend on joue un coup
de fou parce que si on commence à
toucher
ensuite des cinq c'était encore nul mais
bon il y a aucune raison c'est 4 fois 8
joueurs tempo
de la part de Yann les pommiers
tu peux me répondre
salut à toi
nos amis toi
pas de bol quand même l'année dans le
bon département mais pas dans la bonne
ville
ou être dans le bon département mais pas
dans la bonne ville
c'est pas de chance c'est pas passé loin
donc B5 fous des 6 comment il va faire
il va essayer de faire fout becap
et
donc B6
je vois pas trop ce qu'il veut faire il
va faire il y a un moment il veut passer
le roi je comprends pas ce qu'il veut
faire mais
c'est pour ça que il est en train de
jouer pas moi
donc on va voir
G2 qu'est-ce qui fait Magnus
alors il veut essayer de passer par là
mais là le problème c'est qu'elle échec
non
je vois pas en quoi il a amélioré
ça c'est vrai
c'est vrai que mon toit s'en sort mieux
que le chéquier d'acqua effectivement
c'est indéniable ça pas toujours été
comme ça
alors
on fait toujours fou des 6 en fait il a
il a amélioré un petit peu mais bon pas
assez
pas assez Magnus qui a tous ses pions
sur noir et ça l'empêche en fait il y a
une barricade pour les noirs on contrôle
cette case on contrôle cette case quand
il faut et on contrôle cette case quand
il faut et on contrôle tous les accès
ça va être nul
c'est une certitude absolue
quasi absolu
je vois pas comment il peut se tromper
c'est ça le truc
ok il attaque le pion et il va revenir
Magnus qui tourne qui tourne
échec évidemment laisse pas le revenir
quoi qu'on pourrait en fait si le roi
vient F4 il y a 6 et nul signé entre les
deux joueurs
et chaque criard est parti donc je pense
qu'ils vont ils vont reprendre
bientôt je vais aller voir ça ouais non
il y a aucune partie
donc il y a une ule on a est-ce qu'on a
mis les scores mvl aura les Noirs dans
la prochaine
mvl aura les Noirs dans la prochaine
et ils sont à sur le score très
équitable de
demi points à demi points
pas grave il a testé son adversaire il a
très bien joué
merci mais je suis déjà venu à
Mont-de-Marsan merci mon cher
patchoulicho je suis déjà venu un
milliard de fois au minimum mais ça sera
avec plaisir évidemment sur ce
il y a un léger break comme d'habitude
une pause commerciale obligatoire
obligatoire mais on est content de
mettre en valeur ça va faire râler sur
XO mais on met en valeur nos sponsors
secrètes Lab envoyez-moi une chaise
belle chaise secrète la main moi j'en
veux une ensuite
rings
ça me dit quand je j'ouvre pas c'est les
fenêtres et tout ça si mon air est bien
et aussi opéra et oui le meilleur
navigateur j'ai toujours dit
donc voilà on les remercie évidemment de
leur soutien
et
du coup
on se rejoint après la
la pub ciel bleu qui dit que c'est c'est
cher on va peut-être toujours trouvé
tout cher si elle bleu donc oui bah oui
des belles je sais pas c'est combien ça
coûte mais en tout cas des belles
chaises c'est
c'est plus cher qu'une chaise moche
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour pour cette deuxième
partie du match qui va commencer
normalement assez rapidement
la partie commence à 32 les parties
commencent à 32 il est 31 donc voilà on
va voir normalement les deux joueurs qui
sont là avec maximum en bas évidemment à
tourner chez qui une fois qu'ils seront
prêts nul dans la première nulle solide
une Espagnole ou chaque criard a fait
des coups un peu bizarre et que j'ai 5
puis on prend un 4 mais finalement
Maxime qui avait l'air bien au moins
visuellement et bien il a pas obtenu
grand chose malheureusement mais bon une
nul c'est rien de rien de grave voir ce
qui se passe dans cette deuxième partie
et les parties qui vont commencer
vraiment
dans peu de temps est-ce qu'elles vont
être simultanées ou pas
c'est ça la question
est-ce que ça va commencer en même temps
ou pas
ça c'est pas clair
mais Maxime qui aura les Noirs
donc tout va bien
je veux dire c'est pas un drame d'avoir
les Noirs contre chaque crayon on a
aussi des chances il laisse des chances
quoi qu'il arrive
donc clairement
blanc ou noir ça change pas grand chose
waouh Dharma With You qui dit Laurent
est un reportage sur le live anglais
quel reportage
sur le match peut-être
c'est vrai que c'était venu pendant
un stage d'entraînement il était venu
tourner des
des images effectivement d'une 21 avant
le match ça doit être ça
vu que c'est Carlson les pots
c'est vrai que ça serait logique de
montrer les images de ça
alors chaque criard car c'est en Espagne
ouais c'est ça alors ok donc c'était
la prépa du match
n'importe quoi
est-ce que j'ai un temps imprévu le
prochainement non
en novembre
est-ce que c'est prochainement ou pas
novembre
c'est moyen prochainement
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils font la 34 ah il
y a des pommiers avec les Blancs
contre
évidemment Magnus Carlsen on va tout de
suite mettre l'autre aussi
et 5 échecs ok ça c'est surprenant quand
même
tout est surprenant cette partie on voit
Magnus qui joue une Sicilienne dans Le
Mans c'est plutôt des Espagnols contre
les Pau même s'il aime bien tout essayé
et
je ferai le tournoi de Blitz au Cap
d'Agde mais pas pour il y a pas de
trophées cette année et je jouerai pas
l'Open
chaque jour
et donc je crois que je rentrerai à un
moment ou un autre dans le toit de Blitz
dans la salle Molière
pour les habitués du Cap
physique xlos qui demande vision retour
à 2700 non
ça me semble pas réaliste mais
j'aimerais bien
mais je crois pas que ça soit réaliste
donc
non c'est pas un objectif
fou et deux que j'ai FC D3 mais alors ça
c'est vraiment
si on joue des trois voyant n'est pas
très ambitieux sur la Sicile c'est pas
vrai futur ça c'est clair
donc bon pourquoi pas mais effectivement
effectivement c'est pas dingue
dépêchez-vous hein pour le Cap d'Agde
parce que ça va être ça va être
rapidement complet des grands open
français le cap
très prisé
donc moi je vous conseille en tout cas
de réserver avant de pas s'y prendre 3
jours avant
conseil d'amis conseil éclairé
je le sais
les inscriptions
[Musique]
et bien vont
très rapidement
ouais ouais le niveau du top monde a
augmenté ces dernières années ça c'est
sûr
est-ce que Maxime a débuté ou pas je
pense que oui on va regarder
non toujours pas
bon
et à 4 ok on va menacer à 5 en général
les Noirs réagissent par B6 et tout va
bien pour les noirs
c'est assez étonnant que la partie de
Maxime n'est pas reprise on va voir ça
tout de suite
ils ont l'air concentré donc à mon avis
ils ont repris
et oui ça a repris effectivement
et on voit dans cette partie qu'on va
vous mettre en direct et si on
cette partie entre chaque
et Maxime va chier la grave donc une
Antigone ou une Grenelle avec G3 comme
vous voulez et la structure C6 des 5
avec archi solide
pour les Noirs le rock solide qu'on
l'appelle petit encre petit roc et A4 je
voulais pas chaque rayard qui ne
nouvelle variante il y a une petite mode
autour de ça et sur pion prend C4 on
récupère le pion assez facilement
normalement par cavalier à 3 il joue à 5
cavaliers à 3 quand même
et il faut aussi de la part de Maxime
qui connaît très très bien ces systèmes
alors parfois oui c'est ça on pouvait
reprendre du pion alors l'avantage c'est
qu'on pouvait mettre de caler en C6
ensuite mais l'inconvénient c'est quand
donner à casb5 donc le coup vous
prendrez 5 se comprend très bien même si
effectivement on a mis ce pion pour
reprendre en dessin
du pion
mais là on reprend du Fou
il a les Noirs pardon pardon pardon ouh
là là autant pour moi désolé je suis pas
habitué à faire ça évidemment qu'il est
noir
non non il a pas de blanc
il n'a pas de blanc évidemment et donc
il a les Noirs dans cette deuxième
partie
désolé évidemment que c'est la bonne
fête c'est lui c'est lui la grande fête
et joue B3 chaque créa ok il veut sortir
le fou par là jouer éventuellement qui
est C4 c'est encore un coup très logique
même si ça affaiblit un petit peu le pur
en B3 on a une belle case pour le
cavalier en B4
franchement c'est pas une réfutation ça
c'est évident
j'ai oublié d'inverser les chéquiers
tout à fait
ça arrive
ouais c'est un peu vrai que c'est vrai
que A4 et H4 dans les 10 premiers coups
sont quand même très très répandu
alors B3 il réfléchit soit on met le
cavalier ici je pense que c'est ça
l'option soit ici
un des deux
ouais
tout à fait
ça a été
c'est alpha zéro qui nous a montré la
voix cavalier 4 d'abord ok menace plus
ou moins qu'elle était trois pas sûr
ok c'est 5 peut-être
avec le fou qui peut
manger
sur un on joue sur le clouage salut au
chat
et donc fubé 2 a l'air d'être le coup
complètement standard on vient de jouer
B3 c'est clairement pour jouer fou B2 et
qui est C4 donc vous B2 d'abord
peut-être et c'est 4 ensuite quoi que
faut faire peut-être il calcule ce genre
de choses après dame B6 on attaque B3
ce qui se passe
comment on fait maintenant toujours la
même option est-ce qu'on va mettre le
cailler en dessin
a du charme quand même parce que on peut
aller par là on peut aller par là donc
c'est un coup qui se regarde même si le
coup quand la main envie de jouer c'est
cavaliers à 6 pour contrôler cette case
après Maxime aussi les malins donc il
peut tenter un coup internet peut-être
peut-être c'est 5 pour jouer ici pour
jouer sur ce cloud dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure
deux ans que ça n'était pas arrivé vous
savez que ça arrive pas souvent dans les
parties
Pierce Morgane est toujours journaliste
parce que les knackis sont à charcuterie
c'est pas mal ça
c'est étonnant moi je l'ai vu ça
interview aussi de Niman
je sais pas pourquoi il y allait pour la
gloire
je sais pas
on parle de lui
je vois pas l'idée
il aime qu'on parle de lui ce jeune
homme
son déménagement alors tu vas aller où
tu seras combien de stations de métro de
moi
dans la même rue peut-être je sais pas
ouais la fin du de l'interview c'était
compliqué ouais à choisir mais même
station que moi waouh
et ben
ah ben là on sera pas loin là pour le
coup
même si on prend jamais le métro enfin
moi je prends jamais le métro perso
j'habite où dans mes bons artichauts
dans le 11e arrondissement de Paris
et ces quatre cavaliers à 6 jouer par
mvl qui lui habite
pas loin du jardin du Luxembourg
notre ami Maxime
il est à côté
j'habite à Paris dans le 11e
arrondissement
pas loin de Maxime non plus alors c'est
pas la même station de métro mais c'est
quelques quelques kilomètres
j'aime pas le métro moi donc je prends
le je prends ma trottinette
alors fou B2 ouais on peut voir on peut
les voir courir parfois effectivement
qui est décises joué par Maxime qui veut
bien poser une question à se cavalier
c'est vrai que les propres
ça serait assez confort pour les Noirs
clairement on pourrait faire dame B6
ensuite attaquer un petit peu en B3 le
cavalier a une case naturelle donc tout
va bien
tour c'est un kb4 va certainement être
joué par Maxime maintenant il a fait
tous les coups de préparation qui est
semble être un coup et introduit la
menace de cavaliers à deux
et B4 jouer
et oui trottinette électrique
alors sache sur XOS
que Metro sexuel est un terme qu'on
emploie plus voilà pour ta gouverne
alors j'ai dit ça un jeune un jeune
élève que j'ai
une vingtaine d'années
il m'a regardé comme un ça veut dire
quoi c'est un terme c'est vraiment c'est
un terme de boomer
c'est un terme de boomer mais trop
sexuel ça n'existe plus du tout c'est
has been
complet
ah oui je suis pas bien je suis pas bien
en hiver
je reste chez moi en hiver c'est ça
alors kb4 et oui c'est un peu dangereux
mais bon
cavalier à 2 et la menace et on sera
obligé de répéter les coups avec les
Blancs je pense
E3 alors est-ce que cavalier A2 va être
joué ou pas
ça ne m'étonnerait pas du tout cavaler à
deux gens mais peut-être tour à un mais
non toi
et on a perdu un pion ou alors on a
perdu un fou enfin perdu et changer en
tout cas en tout cas sans la paire de
fou on peut rien espérer avec les Blancs
ça c'est une certitude c'est même les
Noirs ici qui sont mieux
donc il me semble que E3 cavaliers à
deux est un vrai coup et surtout C2 hop
le coup du retour en attaque ici comment
on fait avec les Blancs si on bouge la
tour de la colonne c'est on perd le pion
et donc on est obligé de revenir
et donc j'ai l'impression que 3 a une
proposition de nulle implicite alors
après
Maxime j'ai l'impression qu'il a bien
égalisé mais bon et regardez regardez
c'est jouer cavalière de tours de KB 4
tours c'est un ouh là ça répète
ça répète et oui la juger et oui
regardez vous allez avoir nul qui
s'affiche dans quelques instants sous
vos yeux ébahis
nul accordé par les deux joueurs on va
tout de suite filer et oui oui c'est ça
il a complètement en résolu ses
problèmes d'ouverture et bonne nul de
Maxime donc on aura on aura on aura
forcément quatre parties il y a un
partout entre Maxime Vacher la grave
et ça crée un media off je vais me
renseigner évidemment pour savoir si ça
tombe ou pas
c'est pas si ça tombe ou pas
est-ce qu'ils attendent notre match
en tout cas en attendant on va aller
voir
Magnus Carlson et
Yannis avec les Blancs qui a l'air
d'avoir une belle position
après son A4 B6 on avait vu ça F4
[Musique]
et G4
il en a marre il veut tout envoyer là
il faut que j'ai deux certainement pour
faire de la F3 c'est que c'est dangereux
d'un coup
mais attention OK
de donner un pion en Magnus Carlsen et
un deuxième oh là là il a complètement
raté son début de partie il est très mal
Magnus bon et encore un peu de jeu mais
ça a l'air complètement foutu
ouais il est déroutant ma média en
français on sait pas
c'est pas trop ce qu'il fait
alors
il a fait une gaffe des pomiasis tout
d'un coup c'est devenu tout noir
regardez qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
trois est une énorme gaffe et pourquoi
mais pourquoi
il y a ça qui marche
non
quel coup je triche
et je mets à jauge comme Hanson
waouh puis on prend fou prends un jeu de
roi chanté G3
raté par Yann des pomyachi est-ce qu'il
va le voir Magnus Carlsen
ouais ça me donne envie d'aller
récupérer les caméras là
tous ces trois énormes blender et non
c'est même pas la fourchette cavaliers
de la vue Adam F3 mesdames prends j'ai 5
introuvable pas du tout pas du tout
introuvable pas du tout
et ça c'est mat aussi c'est trouvable oh
il a pas joué il a joué
et là ça redevient mieux pour les blancs
oh là là c'était une
c'est une chance incroyable
il a trouvé pour le voir ouais parfois
il faut le voir tout de suite ou on le
voit jamais
c'était incroyable ça me prend j'ai 5
ça aurait été un bon retournement
je sais pas si ça se voit tout de suite
ou pas du tout parfois ouais ouais
souvent c'est comme ça mais pas tout le
temps
alors comment ça marche cette histoire
maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe après
la F3
que les points
V2 et ce cavalier va être enfermé donc à
ce moment-là il faut bouger la tour il
faut jouer ton C2 quelque chose comme ça
ah il y a toujours
j'ai deux
c'est pas clair ce qu'on gagne en
mettant le roi h donc peut-être pour C2
mais non c'est pas bon pour ces deux non
plus alors quelle idée après la F3 j'en
sais rien je triche encore une fois
tourgé deux rois chanter prends des 5
waouh c'est trop et ouais bien vu
sur cahier prend ses trois ça marche pas
du tout parce qu'à tour à trois on se
fait enfermé le cavalier
mais là c'est le coup du retour mais
on a simplement un pion de moins
quelque chose comme ça et c'est très
bien pour les blancs
il a joué à la place
ok dame qui n'est pas du tout critiqué
par la jauge et donc c'est assez mauvais
signe pour Magnus
en jouant c'est ça la c'est ça la
question
et est-ce que Maxime attend ou est-ce
qu'on va avoir la partie tout de suite
ça ça reste aussi un mystère
on va regarder les caméras est-ce que
les joueurs ça fait ou pas non pas du
tout
les joueurs ne sont pas du tout là
alors maintenant comment on fait qui
prend des 5 et perdant à cause de fou
prends B2
pas 50 coups c'est ça le problème
d'accord ok ça c'est le
c'est le problème de commenter sans ordi
c'est qu'on donne un mauvais coup
mais en fait c'est pas si mauvais
peut-être parce qu'elle prend F4 c'est
ça
effectivement le pion G5 est pas facile
à protéger parce que dame G3 il y a
cavalier 2 la fourchette princière
royale bon c'est joué c'est la position
sur l'échiquier qui est 4
et il y a quand même du jeu
parce que une grosse menace alors H4 un
truc comme ça je sais pas
H4 non non
comme H4 ça a pas l'air bon honnêtement
est-ce que ça serait c'est quoi le coup
peut-être pour 8 même pour 8 par exemple
a l'air quand même pas mal vous voyez on
va venir par là
c'est bien terminé donc faut faire
attention comment on fait
pour la chambre peut-être
mauvais aussi tous les coups naturels
sont mauvais
[Musique]
da mash 4
qui a bien meilleur coup d'après la
jauge qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer je
vais revenir
le meilleur coup était sur quel point F4
était la Mascate
et pourquoi roi H1 n'était pas bon à
cause de toi encore une fois OK
donc jouer c'était le meilleur coup et
bien vous voyez c'est de joueurs qui
sont quand même au niveau 1 bon ben
protagoniste dans ma champion du monde
si un j'aime ne voit pas une tactique
visant une humaine
faut-il tout de même une recherche
fait-il tout de même une recherche
tactique
où il est simplement en charge du coup
candidat il peut arriver à la tactique
par déduction vous voyez ouais ouais je
sais pas il y a des pensées plus
ordonnées que d'autres c'est ça même
chez les grands maîtres
même chez les top grand maître même chez
Magnus Carlson je sais pas si toujours
très ordonné chez Magnus
par exemple je pense pas que manus
prennent un coup candidat le calcul
et le calcul jusqu'au bout c'est dire
qu'il a un coup candidat mais il pensait
à un autre à un moment puis un autre et
puis calcule en même temps la variante
c'est pas du tout ordonné
qu'est-ce qu'il dit est-ce qu'il dit
comme moi non
comment on fait ici
oui
[Musique]
mais pour moi c'était pas du tout
ouais moi mon calcul est jamais été très
ordonné honnêtement
c'est toujours été comme ça de je pense
un coup puis un autre et puis c'est de
calculer mais après quand je me fixe sur
un coup j'y arrive mais il y a toujours
un truc qui vient me
il y a toujours un autre coup qui vient
dans la danse
très compliqué à ordonner
je sais pas il y a pas d'impran G5 ouais
madame prend G5 c'est pas mal mais ça
récupère Campion et ça on a la petite
finale donc du coup c'est une belle
tactique mais en vrai
[Musique]
parfois on élimine un coup on se dit que
ça a pas marché
c'est ça et puis vous pouvez faire tous
les entraînements du monde toujours
pareil quand on joue à partir on est
beaucoup plus nerveux beaucoup plus
stressé
beaucoup plus impliqué aussi donc c'est
toujours plus compliqué
moi qui me prend la tête en me disant
que je progresse pas parce que j'arrive
pas à leur donner les coups mes couilles
j'en prends un coup là ouais mais c'est
dur très très
c'est rare d'avoir la
une pensée vraiment ordonnée
alors il a pris en Détroit ouais qui est
très logique
et
[Musique]
donc
poussez trois et logique
comment on fait maintenant
mvl il y a un partout entre mvl et
salut stuff
il a il a un partout là on attend on
attend de voir tiens on va aller voir
c'est une bonne idée ça il est toujours
pas là donc il s'attende toi qui a
commenté le précédent je crois
est-ce que dans le tableau des
vainqueurs oui tu as compté le précédent
parce que tu m'as tu m'as reçu
tu m'as reçu est-ce que dans le tableau
des gagnants il s'attendent pour
commencer
je crois qu'il s'attendent alors il a
joué quoi c'est trois fois cinq et
prends le 5
et toi 1 et oui on a ouvert les colonnes
quand même on a récupéré un pion certes
mais on a quand même ouvert les colonnes
pour les tours et ça a pas l'avantage
blanc tout simplement alors je sais pas
exactement comment il fait jouer avec
les Noirs mais c'est pas évident
tiens l'orange j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour toi
ah bon pas sûr qu'il s'attendent
ils ont fait quoi la dernière fois
c'est ça le truc
chez qui est réel à droite ouais non
j'ai pas changé là effectivement je peux
le changer
ça m'étonne que
il est foutu ma muscarsen clairement
on voit là je vais trop vite c'est quand
même moche et il a même pas obligé de
prendre Yann
et continue comme ça
tu reprends ouais mais j'ai l'impression
que là il s'attendre cette fois
honnêtement
sa caméra c'est quand même bizarre
et ouais non ça c'est mal passé alors
dit effectivement là les colonnes se
sont ouvertes la tour est active on va
faire un coup de dame F5 à un moment si
on échange les dames c'est complètement
terminé ça c'est certain parce que ce
pion on va être perdu certainement
celui-là aussi
et voilà
bon on sait pas de toute façon on va
voir
on va voir si ça tombe ou pas Dame des
quatre échecs ouh ça peut être raté ça
c'est bizarre de laisser faire ça et de
me prendre ces quatre protégerai le pion
oh là là énorme gave de yannashi
il est vraiment au moment de Batman nu à
chaque fois il a un main qui tremble G6
dame F3 mais quel cagad dame desk3 G2
dame prend c'est 4 c'est pas du son
niveau ça c'est un pion un pion net
c'est pas du tout de son niveau de faire
ce genre de gars il perd un pion échec
est prise
incroyable
de faire ça
là il va se voir le faire un dame 6
maintenant c'est pas du tout la même
avec deux pions
ça change tout c'est évident
si ça tombe on n'est pas on n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge quand même et
maintenant
ok peut-être revenir c'est peut-être
même je sais pas qui doit faire
attention peut-être des blancs
ou pas Dame des 7 beaucoup de
remplacement mais c'est vrai qu'avec ce
roi on imagine mal comment on va pas y
avoir un perpétuel pour les Noirs au
minimum
et ouais non mais c'est dur hein c'est
vrai que d'abord il l'a
il l'a complètement honnête il a
complètement massacré au mal champion du
monde le match a duré si parti
Magnus a gagné cette 6e partie qui était
magique évidemment qui est fait
l'histoire en nombre de coups le la
durée de la partie l'intensité de la
partie voilà et après il a explosé en
vol et
c'est vrai que depuis ça n'est pas
vraiment remis il y a une épony Hashi il
a quand même gagné les candidats mais
bon il y a pas de Magnus et ensuite il a
repéré ce match champion du monde contre
Ding ce qui était quand même d'une
manière assez difficile
mais il est encore là quand même il a ce
mérite là
non j'ai pas vu
on se retrouve en trois il nous dit
moi excité à l'idée de jouer mon
vingtième Top 16
les nos amis canaux qui sont remontés
dans l'élite
en tout cas l'élite française par équipe
championnat de France par équipe et 3
et bien on se fait un échiquier c'est
tout enfin c'était dit je prends les
blancs par contre
je te remercie
voilà
je donne une nouvelle chance à ta file
d'or mon cher ami et nul nul accordé oui
c'est dommage quand même c'est un gros
raté là pour Yann les premiers qui
étaient quand même gagnant la plupart de
la partie
mais clairement avec un roi comme ça il
peut pas espérer plus que la nul avec ce
pion ouais il revient de loin bon il
revient de loin il a quand même raté on
va le remontrer il a raté un bel
exercice ici pour ceux qui aiment les
exercices
ouais c'est ça je prends les blancs
contre tout pour garder les Noirs contre
un VLP
maintenant il se dégonfle dans cette
partie enfin je touche du bois attends
Maxime si nous regarde je m'excuse je
m'excuse continue à te dégonfler s'il te
plaît
il a pris les Noirs dernière fois mais
il a été forcé à ce qu'il paraît
je sais pas
peut-être je vais prendre les blancs
aussi on sait jamais pour mettre le
point un peu là
on rappelle gaffe gaffe tous ces trois
qui est très naturel faut C3 c'est vrai
que 3 ça fait une fourchette certes mais
on ce qu'il a joué dame c'était bien
joué après il faut prendre les deux
et on attaque tout sur quel point le
calibre peut pas sortir mais là la
tactique inattendue complètement
inattendu après tout ces trois c'est
dames prend les cinq échecs magnifique
puis on prend G5 fou prends H2 roi H1 et
kg
si c'est pas beau ça
qui trouve dans le prince G5 ouais moi
je me vois pas en train de le voir j'ai
5 ça c'est sûr
Maxime je pense qu'il peut le voir mais
c'est toujours si dur à dire je sais pas
on s'y attend tellement pas c'est ça le
problème c'est que la position est
[Musique]
ouais c'est bizarre que marrant que
Magnus le voit après avoir joué
ça c'est étrange ça c'est le plus
étrange de tout je trouve
parce que normalement si on le voit pas
en jouant on va voir on le voit jamais
quoi
il s'est mis à l'autre bout il bouder
d'accord c'est moi ce que j'ai pas la
caméra parfois mais bon c'est compliqué
de changer en direct en tout cas ce qui
se passe
ce qui se passe c'est que Maxime Vacher
la gravé chaque année un partout marche
très équilibré Maxime elle est blanc
dans la prochaine
l'espagnol de chaque créa elle est quand
même bon elle est
prenablement donc voilà on va essayer de
mettre la pression pour Maxime
sur chaque réa sur son espagnol mais on
voit les deux joueurs qui sont pas là
on voit ouais il y a pas de partie
active donc un partout aussi chez Magnus
Carlsen et chakrama média Rohff donc ça
nous donnera des belles parties en
attendant je fais une toute petite pause
micro pause de 5 minutes et je reviens
pour ces pubs et oui le sait il le sait
stouf il va pas me démentir pour une
fois parce que normalement il me met en
difficulté il essaie de mettre en
difficulté à dire que je mens et tout ça
enfin à me faire avoir mauvaise
réputation
mais les pubs on est obligé de les
mettre
et on les remercie d'ailleurs on est
content merci opéra oh merci streamlab
et on remercie non streamlab c'est ce
que j'ai en face de moi non
secrète Lab c'est les chaises faut qu'il
m'envoie une d'ailleurs je prends comme
le truc rings je préfère la chaise que
le rings
à tout de suite pour ces deux dernières
parties de la journée peut-être à moins
qu'il y a un Armageddon
en fin de journée
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour donc pour cette
dernière ligne droite avec deux matchs à
le temps on a en ce moment même
manus Carlsen à partout contre Yann et
pomyachi il a raté matin 5 coups
de a quasiment jusqu'à Z sauf le l voilà
donc à part tout entre manuscrit et un
partout match très équilibré pour
l'instant en tout cas entre mvl et
chaque rillard mammedia off
tandis que plutôt dans la journée on a
vu à les asafiroja qui jouait pour sa
survie dans le tournoi et qu'il a
emporté après avoir perdu évidemment
hier contre mvl c'est la fameuse double
élimination on n'est pas éliminé tant
qu'on n'a pas perdu deux fois
et ça va bientôt reprendre sa recommence
à 13 selon mes infos
on a évidemment mvl qui va être là on va
recommencer certainement avec la partie
de Magnus d'abord c'est comme ça que ça
marche et 2 minutes plus tard on a
[Musique]
Maxime contre ma média Rohff c'est comme
ça c'est les besoins de la télé
norvégienne qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous dise
santé norvégienne il n'y a pas trop de
tournoi non plus donc c'est toujours
pareil
c'est un peu pénible parfois
effectivement mais c'est eux quand même
qui permettent aussi la tenue de ce
tournoi
donc est-ce que Maxime va répéter son
espagnol très certainement
c'est certainement pas une ligne
bloqueuse
la ligne qui a joué chacun à ma média
Rohff dans l'espagnol c'est ni où ça
joue
peut-être une italienne aussi on sait
pas on va voir
alors ce qui fait mais
bon pas de quoi pas de quoi s'inquiéter
pour
pour Maxime
ni pour chaque crayon d'ailleurs
alors on va voir quand est-ce qu'il est
reprennent Maxime qui a fait nul très
très facilement avec les noirs
il y a pas eu de photos et on voit
chaque air qui se lève qui attend
c'est bizarre c'est match après il y a
pas de pause c'est un peu pénible mais
qu'elle a trop de pause c'est pénible
aussi le mieux c'est 5 10 minutes et
[Musique]
on va voir on va voir ce que Laurent
Blanc a décidé oui pour la pour
l'ouverture avec les Blancs est-ce qu'on
joue en 4 4 2 en 4 3 3 en tout cas on
est ravi de revoir Maxime à ce très très
haut niveau
clairement il laisse pas de chance pas
de gaffe pas de coup de jouer trop vite
il se
hâte moins prend plus son temps tout en
regardant un bon rythme donc voilà ça a
l'air vraiment parfait et au tata style
rapide il avait emporté de manière fort
brillante
normalement Magnus devrait quand même
bientôt et oui oui ça y est Magnus a
repris on va aller voir ça tout de suite
et
Magnus joue donc encore une pétrole
avec
des six
ok c'était par le match championnat du
monde ça a été joué tout ça
normalement c'est censé être ok
évidemment pour les Noirs mais il a
peut-être une petite idée c'est ton
jamais
quelque chose qui reste du mal ou pas
quelque chose qui a été retravaillé
on ne sait pas on va voir mais en tout
cas ça sera quelque chose de tranquille
parce qu'on voit la position noire qui
est quand même pas qui est assez saine
on va développer le cavalier par là
peut-être fou j'ai 5 je crois que c'est
le coup faut G5 et on essaie d'obtenir
un léger plus une légère initiative
que malus Carlsen affectionne
particulièrement
je vais quand même aller voir ouais non
les deux joueurs pensif donc ils ont pas
repris là c'est clair
on va quand même voir on va on va rester
sur ça là évidemment c'est Magnus face à
face à un dépôt
c'est pas la partie de MVM mais j'ai
l'impression que ça
ça va jouer là où ça rejoue déjà non
ça joue pas encore
alors nepo qui essaie de se souvenir de
sa prépa certainement qui est 17 à la a
l'air normal
c'est qui bonjour préférée aux échecs
Laurent Blanc non garrix quand même
héros de jeunesse
la Métro en attaque le pion
très logique et pas de Magnus qui arrive
à surprendre
à chaque fois
à chaque fois Yann dans ces petites
prépas de pétrole et ça a repris comme
prévu et c'est chaque rieur qui change
alors ça c'est une petite surprise
on va voir qu'est-ce qu'il fait sur ce
système
je vous mets la partie en direct aussi
ça va être intéressant alors il y a deux
deux écoles clairement que je vais vous
montrer tout de suite deux écoles pour
les blancs soit on fait ses ah mais
c'est la troisième école
donc deux écoles j'allais dire si on
fait des câbles directement
soit on fait ces trois pour préparer des
quatre mais il y a la troisième école
c'est de faire ces quatre parce qu'en
fait les noirs
menacent quand même de faire baisser un
cavaliers à 5 en fermant entre
guillemets le foot casse blanche on n'a
pas envie de donner ce fou d'attaque
de copier castrov quand j'étais jeune
pas connu jeune pietrox 51 alors C4 et
la G5 waouh chakra toujours
toujours alerte sur ce genre de choses
et des quatre G4 et on fait des 5 j'ai
déjà vu ce truc là quelque part
je sais pas je sais pas c'est toujours
toujours un petit peu douteux puis on
prend F3 puis on prend c'est 6
simplement on est obligé de reprendre on
peut pas reprendre ici parce qu'il y a
plus on prend des 7 échecs et on perdra
une pièce
donc on doit prendre du pion du Fou et
ensuite on va reprendre de la dame ici
par exemple je vois pas trop l'intérêt
de garder les fous de casse blanche donc
plutôt fous prends ces 6
vous prend ces 6 puis on prend ses 6 dam
point F3
et c'est très chaud mais c'est souvent
chaud pour les Noirs ce genre de choses
vous voyez chaque rayard qui quand même
qui donne des chances clairement
l'espagnol avec G5 G4 il commence à
réfléchir en plus ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle
je sais pas ce qu'il veut faire là je
sais pas quoi y réfléchit à Papy on
prend F3 cavalier 7 est vraiment tout
moche à mon avis faut prendre des sets
dame prend cavalier C3 ensuite purger
c'est pas clair ce qu'il fait il y a pas
une grosse attaque sur le roi blanc
ça semblerait quand même bizarre de
jouer comme ça
alors cavalier
ce pion alors c'est clair c'est vraiment
l'éclaireur ce pion dans ce genre de cas
on se demande il y a pas une grosse
attaque pour les noirs
c'est compliqué
déjà mal Mamadou il fait n'importe quoi
dans les débuts
la jauge à Montreuil un avantage de déjà
plus un après faut prendre des sets
d’âme prendre essai de cavaliers H4 la
jauge montre plusieurs rendez-vous
compte il fait n'importe quoi dans les
débuts
plus un vin d'après ma jauge chascom qui
est quand même pas mauvaise sur ça F3
H5 qui est C3 et surtout F6 on fait quoi
on fait damer
et là c'est du plus 1,30
et ben il fait qu'il y avait H4
directement Maxime va chez Lagrave OK
pourquoi c'est moins bon parce que B5
ouais c'est énorme plus un à ce stade
ouais c'est dingue c'est dingue
B5 peut-être mais bon
quand même quand même
ouais
j'ai allumé le stream il m'a imité
l'autre jour arrudisky j'étais flatté
évidemment d'être imité par un arrondiki
mais je trouvais je trouvais ça assez
mauvais
imiter mon accent anglais
je suis d'accord mais là je trouvais ça
assez mauvais franchement
pas du tout ressemble Peter et
et il a trouvé ça aussi pas terrible
se fait bien
l'accent français
pourtant il limite bien
normalement
alors B5 et oui B5 pour pas justement
pour contrôler cette case F5 deux fois
pour qu'il y ait pas de Cali F5 et un
cavalier 6 possible
mon B5 a priori on prend pas on revient
sagement en B3 mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'il a chauffe chaque oui ah il est pas
content vous avez vu Maxime
il s'est dit mais pourquoi j'ai pas
appréhendé 7 évidemment évidemment
pourquoi j'ai pas pris en 7
est-ce que c'est un bon coup maintenant
que certainement
et les blancs sont bien
ok donc on peut pas faire ça d'abord
peut-être faut que j'ai cette fois F6
d'abord je pense que c'est deux options
j'en vois pas d'autre
cavalier F6 peut-être pour attaquer au 4
c'est sur quel site Royal B4
alors foo B3 fuj G7 ok pour faire faux
F6 assez clairement
salut time échec 2008
ouais il limite bien les Russes Damien
du reste
c'est un des rares que je regarde
honnêtement je regarde rarement déjà des
streams
mais quand il y a vraiment un truc qui
m'intéresse
je regarde la route qui en général je
trouve c'est bon
alors j'ai trois et ouais il veut il
veut se faire cette
bon coup là Maxime il faut prendre
important de liquider ce foodcesse
blanche qui est qui est crucial là pour
le contrôle de cette case et surtout F6
son idée c'est de revenir en G2 tout
simplement
mais c'est pas extraordinaire
c'est qui le pire j'aime de l'histoire
j'adore
c'est génial de penser à des trucs
pareils
je sais pas
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire chaque
peut-être H5 d'abord
voici c'est la logique quand même que
j'ai deux et puis voilà chaque créa
c'est pas pour c'est pas pour me lire
maintenant
donc je pense que c'est ça son idée
je pense qu'il va faire ça mais il prend
beaucoup de temps c'est bien pour nous
ça dommage quand même de Maxime de pas
avoir pris en 17 là il va ça peut coûter
cher ce genre de choses
ça changeait tout
vous faire un coup comme F5 ça serait
lui ça aussi je vois H5 moi en général
je devine pas un coup donc H5
normalement ne va pas arriver mais si et
si si si il me fait mentir
à 5 jouets
ouais bah oui il s'est gonfle pas ça
craint il est pas là pour ça ok c'est
trop il y a tout le temps B4 qui
m'embête un peu on sait pas trop où
mettre ce cavalier
peut-être on peut jouer fouger 5 là pour
essayer de
chatouiller un petit peu les Noirs
essayer de forcer FO F6 il a quand
embêtant ce fou
et c'est vrai que si
peut-être Dame des deux quand même
non Dame des deux il aime pas
peut-être que G6 là ouais simplement
avec surfer
intéressant
on prépare un développement assez
classique finalement
de cavalier C3 ou cavaliers des deux
suivi de tour C1 essayer de faire
pression sur ce pion en CCF qui est
quand même une faiblesse chez les noirs
je suppose que chaque arrière va jouer
fou F6 à moins qu'il ait décidé de me
faire mentir jusqu'au bout
il faut H4 et puis bon je sais pas trop
où ça mène mais pourquoi pas ouf 6 qui
est G2 et G6 quelque chose comme ça et
H4
Fuger 5 ce genre de choses je pense que
c'est ça qui est favori
ouais ce vide-leur
moi j'ai commenté avec lui c'est pas
évident parce qu'il parle beaucoup il
parle énormément
c'est dur dans placer une
les coups ouais style aussi différent ça
dépend il y a pour tous les goûts
c'est vrai
les coups après
il parle que d'échec 100% mais bon en
même temps ça se streamer
attention
il est comme ça dans la vie parle
beaucoup aussi
donc
qui sont
des vrais passionnés
surtout l'écho
c'est vraiment impressionnant pour le
coup
à 3h du mat il y a encore
il y a encore c'est ça les coups il
serait capable de commenter ça 12 heures
par jour
il y a aucun problème
pénible
s'il te plaît échec merci Arios
alors qu'est-ce qui nous fait chaque
mais il réfléchit
et ben c'est pas mal ça
c'est pas mal pour nous
ouais c'est vrai que guéri est pas
mauvais aussi
il faut avouer
comme commentateur il est bon je suis
assez d'accord
et reviens
il veut faire il veut faire quoi il veut
faire 5 du coup proposition de nul
tacite de la part de chaque rillard oh
il revient il fait toujours des couilles
archi surprenants il veut faire F5 les
cavaliers F6 sans que ça soit possible
de prendre un F5 est-ce que Maxime va
revenir ou pas
alors comment on peut faire si on veut
pas répéter les coups mais après on se
développe alors soit ici soit ici est-ce
que c'est grave ça
me laisse rien pourquoi pas ton C1
franchement bon bah alors après c'est
vrai que c'est sympa on a l'impression
d'avoir une indienne avec quelques temps
plus mais en même temps
toujours pareil je sais pas si on prend
ici peut-être
c'est chaud
et c'est jouer qui ait des deux F5
jouets il a pas voulu annuler mvl pour
revenir ici peut-être aussi
très intéressant cette position vous
voyez le chaos qui arrive à mettre sur
échiquier
ça crée à ma média enfin vraiment il
cherche à aller chercher les embrouilles
il est quand même assez incroyable j'ai
5 ou 6e coup
alors c'est toujours un peu
un peu douteux mais ça nous donne des
parties
assez originales c'est pas bon du tout
là d'après la jauge j'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi
cette F4 allez F4 et c'est jouer F4 au
moment j'ai joué il a été joué tout seul
allons-y
allons-y je pourrais les remettre les
jingles je crois que ça marcherait
et on ouvre ça pourquoi parce que le roi
est en 8
et donc là c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué pour les noirs de tout
ouvrir si on fait plus on prend on peut
gagner un pion ici mais qui
franchement les pions c'est pas très
intéressant cette position apparemment
il vaut mieux reprendre du Fou
pour mettre le caler en E3 je suppose et
sur quel F6 on va avoir E5 certainement
et oui la jauge qui commence à
comprendre
ce qui se passe et ça serait très
délicat F4 très bien joué la part de
Maxime voyez là toute sortie comme quoi
les vieilles règles aux échecs ça peut
s'appliquer contre ce roi qui est au
centre et ce cavalier qui est pas encore
sorti
et la grosse pression sur ma média off
grosse pression
je vois pas ce qui va être obligé quand
même de il peut pas laisser prendre
parce que là on peut plus jamais ok du
coup il y aura toujours des six échecs
donc ça n'irait pas du tout
moi-même revenir ici et il a pris un F3
en passant
OK
pourquoi pas
pour venir en G5 et éventuellement un
jour aussi
peut-être qu'avait les H4 ici aussi je
sais pas j'aime bien parce que ça donne
du travail à se cavalier donc je préfère
reprendre du cavalier il a repris de la
dame assez vite ok cavalier fait mentir
lui aussi toi aussi Maxime tu me fais
mentir
je croyais que c'était le truc de chat
cria
les deux étaient tentants faut avouer
cavalier FC c'est certainement même
peut-être cavalier H4 pour menacer de
prendre un F5
intéressant aussi
que les H4 jouer par mvl
qui a une belle position là d'un coup
quoi d'autre qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant on peut pas prendre on peut
pas tout ouvrir si on ouvre tout qui est
prend on a déjà des menaces beaucoup
trop fortes là ok il peut venir là on
peut jamais prendre ici évidemment ça
serait maintenant un
donc ça n'irait pas donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on est obligé de donner
un pion et après petit rang puis on
prend F5 et puis faut prouver les
compensations qui sont pas claires
et attention
attention
non la retransmission est pas bloqué mon
cher
bleu j'ai juste un peu d'avance sur vous
parce que j'ai les parties en direct
j'ai les cours en direct du coup
ce qu'il y a pas beaucoup de sens c'est
vrai effectivement vous pouvez voir sur
le stream
et F4
encaisser ça c'est fait
et que j'ai 4 ok ok ok donc les bon
après puis on prend 5 il va y avoir des
compensations évidentes quoique
attention
grosse menace
oh là là que c'est bizarre pour les
noirs
domicile
ou quelque chose
ça serait vraiment pas clair
donc comment on fait sur kg 4
on veut ok les Noirs clairement on peut
aussi c'est quand même un pion passé
protéger ça se respecte
ou pas nous dire qu'on pourrait faire
petit rock ou F6 et ça pourrait être pas
clair du tout
moyen peu de jeu c'est compliqué et il
prend le 5 Maxime va chez Lagrave
je rapide de la part de Maxime mais pas
trop quel prends 5 et maintenant on a un
pion de plus et surtout et surtout peut
avoir des pions dans ces positions c'est
tellement tellement ouvert il y a
tellement de jeux de pièces
que bon le compte des pions finalement
il est pas si important
MG2 tour G8 foudé un proposé par iosha
alors ouais intéressant intéressant
foutez un c'est vrai que ça menace une
grosse menace ça c'est c'est moi qu'on
puisse dire peut-être que j'ai 4 j'en
sais rien je sais pas ce qu'on fait
je ne sais plus j'en perds mon latin
peut-être fou j'ai 4 faut j'ai quatre
bof bof mais bon peut-être avec fof-6
derrière c'est une pagaille
indescriptible
en général j'aime pas jouer la G2 parce
que c'est le premier coup j'ai proposé
vous me direz mais à la réflexion quand
même ça crée un vis-à-vis avec la tour
qui peut être désagréable mais où c'est
que je la mets madame alors j'ai trois
bon non je voulais pas la mettre sur la
colonne g mais c'est vrai que j'avais
pas trop d'autres cases en fait
donc je donne un principe général qui ne
s'appliquait pas ici parce que
il y avait pas de meilleure case
par exemple sur dame de fou j'ai quatre
périodes du temps ça peut être
désagréable
donc dame j'ai trois tours G8 joue à
tempo et roi H1 on se on s'enlève des
de l'enfilade
et maintenant c'est vrai une découverte
il faut F6 on va simplement faire
dame quelque part alors dame si la F2 ok
G4 à mon avis quoi
encore ça ça tient faut prendre H4 pas
possible
donc c'est jouable
mais on ne rentrera pas a priori à moi à
moins d'un grand rock
je sais pas j'aime bien les blancs
j'aime bien les blancs à cause de la
situation des rois qui est quand même
plus stable chez les Blancs pas beaucoup
vous me direz mais quand même
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire d'un F4 ici
et ranger 7 peut-être ton premier f63 G7
donc
alors maintenant faut choisir une bonne
case pour la dame
alors les options c'est ici ici et ici
ici ça a l'air assez pauvre
mais bon peut-être
pourquoi pas après tout ça master 3
ça libère donc peut-être dameur qui est
des trois c'est pas grave il y a même
deux
en même temps et ça gagne
gros choix là pour Maxime mais chaque
criard qui quand même qui défie mvl dans
les complications
ça peut se retourner contre lui
alors
est-ce que ça c'est un est-ce que ça
c'est une option ou pas
j'ai l'impression que oui
parce que quoi
fouder un peu arriver qu'il y a F3 aussi
même ce genre de choses parce que le
cavalière quand même très fort hors du
mal à OK
si on fait d'un B8 MBC ça prend
énormément de temps et on pourra
toujours pas ok parce que le cavalier
sera en prise donc ça ça n'irait pas
dames joué par mvl
j'aime bien en fait
après
[Musique]
les blancs sont gagnants apparemment ici
pourquoi
que j'ai quatre jouets
et les jouets 4 Maxime qui semble pas le
meilleur d'après leur dire on va
regarder qui a été meilleur coup
c'était eux 5 quoi ça c'est dur mais
thématique il faut prendre 5 fois F4 et
comme je vous avais dit peu importe les
pions
peu importe les pions ici on joue
l'initiative et c'était le meilleur coup
mais il a joué F4 qui ne gâche rien
apparemment
mais qui donne un avantage moins
conséquent
5 30 contre 4,30 pour jouer cette
position incroyable
incroyable c'est très chaud c'est
peut-être là où se joue le match que
j'ai 6 finalement
peut-être 5 quand même 5 à l'air plus
naturel ou pousser deux
cinq c'est hyper tentant là pour ouvrir
les lignes et faire jouer cette dame
et le cavalier peut venir en E4 ça a
l'air très fort quand même quand on le
regarde ce coup de 5
je pense qu'il va jouer Maxime
je le vois en train de jouer au 5
allez
en plus avec le zaynote qui approche
c'est quand même hyper tentant
de jouer e58
est-ce qu'il va faire ça maximum ou pas
Peugeot aussi cavalier F3 ouais j'ai le
dire pour jouer 5 il a failli jouer 5 je
pense
c'était meilleur
c'était largement meilleur dame cette
peut-être
ah non là on passe pas sur Magnus bobo
on passera pas sur Magnus dans cette
position là c'est quand même assez assez
bouillante ici
donc on reste sur sur mvl évidemment
alors je peux vous faire une update
Magnus pour avoir des ça sur mon
téléphone vite fait et vous dire comment
il est
la magie du direct
comment aider ma niche Carson il est gay
complètement gagnant Magnus Carlsen
dans cette pétrole
c'est complètement gagnant pour Magnus
et c'est tout sauf une surprise
tellement il a la main sur Yann des
pomyachi
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire chaque
crieur prend ton temps chaque criard une
minute d'avance pour mvl
qui menace vraiment le 5 là c'est une
grosse merde donc c'est pour ça que dame
7 me semblait être très logique si on
met un truc en E5 ça va être échangé
donc on a un pion de moins quand même
on a plus de moi ça facilite je des
blancs donc quoi d'autre à part dame 7
quoi d'autre franchement
je vois pas oh il prend deux
là ça commence à devenir ça commence à
être chaud quand même
faut être gentil chat créa qu'il est pas
bien
5 Scipion prend qu'elle prend et la dame
derrière là dans la bon Maxime
allez Maxime allez
le roi est tellement dans les courant
d'air je sais pas un truc comme ça même
ça ça a l'air complètement gagnant
on va simplement sur dmf6 qui protège un
peu ça on va faire je sais pas
faire attention à pas se tromper quand
même est-ce que ça a gagné pas du tout
et ça c'est pas gagnant pas du tout
ça ça c'est pas mal ça ça attaque la
tour ça me laisse des découvertes mais
ça a l'air tellement gagnant je veux
dire on est sûr qu'on est gagné après le
5 allez
allez
ouais certaines prépas de Magnus peut
être encore d'actualité oui c'est sûr
contre Yann contre n'importe qui parce
que il y a quand même un gros travail
qui est fait pour un championnat du
monde donc on peut en profiter quand
même pendant deux trois ans
donc là on arrive probablement sur la
fin mais bon et dame 7 mais c'est un
désastre pour chacun me met des sachets
et il fait aussi évidemment il donne la
qualité surtout il va faire dame et
attention ça peut venir par là après
oh je vois tellement en train de jouer
ça c'est tellement un coup à la maxime
évidemment ce pion il vaut plus que le
fou finalement
il est ici paralyse complètement l'armée
des noirs
ça va être joué je pense
et c'est jouer
et ça a l'air tellement terminé vous ces
8 c'est pas un coup c'est 8 c'est
abandon c'est pareil avec un roi pareil
et il fait grand rock ouais voilà c'est
ça
j'ai l'impression qu'on prend toujours
pas là on va on va essayer de
chatouiller le roi noir en faisant un
truc comme ça autour c'est un peu tête
ou tours c'est pas bon du tout il y a
cavalier F2
encore peut-être Dame des quatre d'abord
pour préparer
on peut prendre aussi
je sais pas on n'a pas envie de prendre
quand même
c'est normal de pas prendre le fou là
et pousser deux attaque la tour ok
apparemment c'est pas le plus précis
mais ça a l'air très humain très logique
on est obligé de partir sur la colonne g
soit ici soit ici parce que sur ton FC
sur un fou G5 ça n'ira pas
comment on fait sur tous ces deux
il veut faire que je suppose
il veut bien la tour dans un premier
temps c'était pas le bon coup et il
prend maintenant et maintenant il va en
mettre un cavalier ici pour faire 5 donc
ici
c'est peut-être l'idée
certainement même deux vins contre deux
trente
Maxime machinagrave complètement gagnant
objectivement parlant mais attention il
faut encore terminer le travail il a vu
d'autres chakria il menace wave 5 ici
j'ai l'impression que tu aurais fuites
et le bon coup ici bon même si c'est
foutu hein c'est sûr
mais c'est une telle pagaille que il
faut encore gérer le la fin j'ai trois
et vous voyez je fais des gaffes
pourquoi c'est une gaffe ça j'ai quand
même regarder avec la jauge cavalier de
3 maintenant oui ça peut tourner vite un
mauvais coup et
ça tourne et toi fuite a été joué alors
attention pas fou G3 on a vu le coup
qu'il fallait pas jouer joue cavalier
aussi évidemment qui est bien meilleur
s'organiser pour mettre quelque chose en
CE1 peut-être jouer à 4 aussi ouvrir ce
côté là
Magnus a gagné Magnus mène par 2 à 1 et
c'est tout le mal qu'on souhaite
à
mvl2 sur la même route que Magnus et de
croiser ça route dès demain
on pourra une belle finale entre mvl et
Magnus Carls and full 4 bien joué petit
coup de centralisation là ça me plaît
bien même si les gens j'aime pas trop
alors faut faire attention toujours il y
a pas de oursin à cause de cavalier 2
mais c'est vraiment la seule arnaque des
noirs
en même temps il y a pas de bon conseil
ici alors l'idée principale c'est si on
prend en passant dame prend le 6 et donc
de plus avoir ce fameux tours c'est un
avec tours français 7 mais il est
gagnant à la maxime
complètement gagnant
c'est complètement sûr
comment on fait
ou d'un meurt joli coup géométrique
menace d'un Massac
et comment on fait avec les Noirs ici la
massette OK
il fallait empêcher absolument de mettre
est-ce que je peux prendre ici ou pas
j'aime pas trop ça parce que ça va
ouvrir la grande diagonale peut-être
d'un point à deux va arriver tu reprends
F1 dans
chaque ici dame de
protège et attaque c'est les meilleurs
ceux-là on adore
on adore ce genre de coup
comment on fait avec les Noirs peut-être
C4 mais c'est quand j'ai l'impression
que même H3 a l'air bon
ben je travaille pas mal descend pas
trop merci
c'est 4h
très rapidement une minute contre 25
faut faire attention au temps quand même
mais pour l'instant il est en contrôle
Maxime
qui était vraiment cool évident ce
cavalier a aussi c'est un monstre ça a
l'air complètement gagnant pour les
blancs cavalier 3 waouh ça c'est ça
c'est lui ça et tout rêve de simplement
l'idée rapidement sur 3T de jouer tout
reprend F1 et d'un point 3 on avait du
contre-jour mais je tournef 2 il attaque
le cavalier qui est pas un bon coup
apparemment kf5 mais là les joueurs je
vont bientôt jouer sur la seconde il
reste plus qu'une minute aux deux
joueurs
c'est très chaud cavalier F5 tours G2 ah
pas mal
comptez sa colonne g et si on prend ici
dame prend menace dame G8 et ça a l'air
complètement terminé
et oui ces autres gagner des parties
pour prendre jouer c'est sûr
c'est pas sûr parce que faut prendre
aussi attaque attaque le pion là-bas
mesdames telles gros échec en G8 que
c'est tentant aussi
et prends G2 jouer ok et vous décidément
d'un prince 5 est une énorme menace
aussi de toute façon j'ai l'impression
que ici tous les chemins mènent à Rome
il ne va pas falloir se tromper d'un
pour porter la dernière estocade
mais ça devrait être bon
ça devrait être bon qu'est-ce qu'on joue
la tour à 7 c'est trop moche c'est trop
passif ton rachète il jouera jamais un
coup comme ça mais comment on protège 5
bien malin bien malin celui qui s'est
répand à cette question je crois qu'on
peut on peut pas le protéger
il y a peut-être aussi des kg 8
attention comment on fait pour
l'empêcher je crois qu'on peut pas
l'empêcher à 8 secondes pour chacun ma
meilleure offre qui doit résoudre des
problèmes insolubles c'est un sent bon
pour le français
ok dame j'ai 8 échec bon là on va passer
par derrière ouais mais c'est un bref 7
et 8 c'est fini même tactique fraise la
vue celle-là et oui c'est jouer et ça
abandonne victoire de Maxime va chez
Lagrave qui prend la tête dans ce dans
ce match
et
qui mène donc de 1
2 1 pour mvl face à chaque fois dernière
et une nul sera suffisante pendant ce
temps Magnus Carson la aussi emporté
face à Yann epomashi ça y est ça se
débloque et les deux joueurs avec les
Blancs ont marqué un point mais
attention attention ouais très très fort
il a très bien joué clairement
grosse partie attention quand même
ce n'est pas terminé il faudra ne pas
perdre la dernière parce que perdre la
dernière équivaut à jouer à Armageddon
et donc effectivement on n'a pas envie
de cette armaguer donc quand on mène
dehors
ouais chaque criard qui a été quand même
un peu trop large
alors je vais vous dire un cœur ça
reprend
ou mauvaise nouvelle
j'ai l'heure laquelle ça reprend ça
reprend à 22 heures tout rond dans 8
minutes
belle belle page de pub là
mais en tout cas ouais c'est un généreux
c'est un généreux chaque
ouais la combinaison finale était quand
même pas très compliquée pour la
fourchette alors de toute façon il
pouvait rien faire
qu'est-ce qu'on a terminé le travail sur
roi des selles je sais pas Damas 8
menace un coup
comment on faisait on faisait ça le
petit escalier oui je sais que c'est
ça n'allait pas du tout
donc reprise des parties ça roule pas
direct du tout
et donc on va avoir la dernière partie à
22h il faut absolument tenir pour Maxime
mâcher la grave mais il est bon il est
bon dans ce tournoi il est bon dans les
précédent tournois il a pas eu de
problème avec les Noirs dans la deuxième
donc il y a pas de raison
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il la tienne
pas cette dernière partie en tout cas on
est optimiste et pour manuscrit ça sera
exactement la même équation il faudra
faire nul contre Yann et paumes
ça sent bon pour notre fille de rêve
finale de rêve
maxime est grave dès demain merci où on
se rejoint comme tous les jours à partir
de 18h c'est le programme jusqu'à
vendredi
du coup moi je vais faire un break
commercial
parce que
ce qu'on me demande de faire en vantant
les mérites de nos sponsors
on sait pas mais voilà
sur ce on se rejoint dans quelques
petites minutes pour cette dernière
partie peut-être de la journée ou pas ou
pas ça peut être
on peut avoir un Armageddon si un des
deux joueurs arrive à revenir au score
il y a des premiers chèques les blancs
ou chacun va venir au fait avec les
Blancs qui doivent absolument gagner
à tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour donc pour cette
dernière partie de la journée on espère
en tout cas du côté français vu que
Maxime Vacher La Grave mène de 1 contre
chacun m'améliorof une nulle et c'est
bon une nulle et c'est bon ça va
recommencer ça va reprendre sa reprise
chez Magnus Carlson
je vais vous montrer ça tout de suite
Magnus Carlsen qui est donc avec les
pièces noires
face à Yann epomashi décide de jouer une
nage d'orf et ben dis donc
alors qu'il a besoin simplement de nul
je monte pas le son pendant la pub là
c'est la pub qui est un peu plus fort
toi c'est possible je peux la baisser
alors dame c'est 7 ok pourquoi pas en
général on peut par kb7 et B5 et suivi
de fou B7 c'est comme ça que les Noirs
se développent généralement
c'est pas censé c'est pas censé être
très dangereux pour les Noirs mais bon
ça joue
ça joue hein il veut faire ça et ça il
va jouer vite il y a des pommiashi mais
évidemment on va suivre
en priorité la partie
de mvl
on va voir ça tout de suite dès qu'ils
vont reprendre
mais c'est pas il y a toujours deux
trois minutes d'écart
et vous arrivez au bon moment si vous
nous rejoignez maintenant
c'est la partie décisive la partie qui
ne faut pas perdre pour ma muscarsen et
pour mvl pour une finale de rêve en tout
cas pour nous
mvl contre Magnus mvl qui est tellement
fort en ce moment qui pourrait bien
faire trembler le l'ogre norvégien ce
qui gagne tout
sachant que le vainqueur de demain de la
finale
aura une journée de repos jeudi il
attendra son adversaire du vendredi
il faudra que son adversaire le battre
deux fois donc autant vous dire que
c'est une grosse option de gagner
aujourd'hui et demain clairement
alors on va voir si
Maxime
sont bientôt en place c'est pas la
position de Maxime ça hein Maxime toute
façon aura les Noirs j'en profite pour
tourner chez qui
et ensuite on va aller voir évidemment
Maxime va chez La Grave
là on a Magnus qui joue une position
archi tendue naydorf archi tendu c'est
pas trop son genre mais bon pourquoi pas
il est tellement en confiance en ce
moment qui sent capable de tout faire
c'est souvent comme ça
et on a ce qui s'est cinglé déjà
cavalier 5 peut-être pour C8 ça a l'air
très harmonieux pour les noirs
honnêtement là cette dame en F3 qui fait
pas grand chose qui est dans le
vis-à-vis
pas très impressionnant sur cette up de
la part des blancs
alors je vais aller voir vite fait si
Maxime
a pas commencé c'est quand même pas
complètement impossible et il a commencé
Maxime La Grave et on va voir tout de
suite on a un gamme accepté
et oui plus qu'on fait c'est sa deuxième
arme c'est l'arme du moment
on va tourner chez qui si on veut me
faire tirer les oreilles et Maxime va
chez Lagrave a donc les noirs
face à ma média off et une nul
nous arrange bien et j'ai quatre déjà
partis alors on va voir au ralenti ce
que ça a donné envie d'un accepter tout
à fait
tout à fait standard ça devait rentrer
avec B3 qui est quand même une des
ventes principales ces jours-ci
j'ai déjà vu Maxime jouer ça j'ai quatre
et en fait un coup un coup recommandé
par l'ordi dans ce genre de position
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est pas bien
développé donc j'ai 4g5 pour
déstabiliser ce cavalier c'est pas
simplement chaque rire qui peut jouer ce
genre de choses mais là il s'est préparé
apparemment pour prendre à me prendre
j'ai 5,8 H4 en fait ça prend l'espace
et c'est toujours un peu désagréable
pour les Noirs alors ça reste très
solide évidemment pas de faiblesse mais
initiative du côté blanc
et sachant qu'une nul
est quand même
gagne le match tout simplement demain
c'est 18h 18h à lireza et a priori
on espère en tout cas 20h pour Maxime
s'il fait nul ou s'il gagne cette partie
ça sera 20h pour Maxime pour la grande
finale contre le King norvégien Magnus
Carlson a priori si Magnus ne perd pas
non plus
mais ça avait l'air déjà bien parti dans
l'autre partie qui est des 6 très solide
comment on va faire
quand on va faire avec les avec les
Blancs là pour continuer l'initiative
peut-être un coup de prise ici quoi
qu'on n'aime pas trop ça fait jouer la
tour et amener la dame par là mais bon
ça devrait être c'est normalement si les
Noirs jouent précis il s'en sortent
et fougère on garde les fous mais alors
à quel prix on sait quand même bien
ouvert ici bon apparemment c'est le coût
de la jauge donc ça peut pas être
complètement mauvais
qui est ici ça a l'air vraiment normal
ici ok
pas si mauvais non plus
il y a l'option il va falloir sortir ce
cavalier de toute façon
donc ça va clairement ce jouet entre K
et 6 et cavalier des 7
on va voir ce que va décider Maxime
cette qualité 7 pour faire cavalier 5
ensuite
ce qui est une histoire sur E6 c'est ça
l'histoire c'est quoi l'envoyer c'est ça
non c'est pas ça
je sais pas pourquoi la jauge réagis
comme ça sur CA7 non non c'était une
fausse alerte qui est 17 et très viable
avec cavalier 5 qui peut arriver
a toujours ce problème de la tour
ça c'est le c'est le principal problème
des Noirs dans cette ligne c'est cette
tour en A7 qui est quand même pas
terrible il faut bien dire ce qui est
mais bon une fois qu'on a résolu ça mais
on a égalisé c'est ça l'enjeu
ouais c'est sûr que c'est agréable quand
de ma média off il envoie tout ah ouais
non toujours
c'est pas parce qu'il pense que Maxime
elle est nul
c'est parce que il joue comme ça
ok fouet 8 alors ça
j'ai pas la f j'ai l'impression que ça
les sagesse 5 en plus j'aime pas trop
parce que le fou
attaqué j'ai 5 et 5 G6 peut être une
menace
j'ai le camion là camion poubelle
j'espère qu'on l'entendez pas il passe
en bas
sur H5 G6 des noirs
j'aime pas
j'aime pas parce que
alors peut-être mais bon même H6
et faute H5 a été joué donc on va voir
qualité de Maxime mais bon en même temps
j'ai 6 menaces donc quoi d'autre
on l'entend complètement
ouais il y a beaucoup de déchets à
ramasser là
je peux aller fermer la fenêtre de ce
pas
on l'entend complètement ouais mais
c'est vrai que c'est dur de pas
l'entendre
et ouais mardi soir tous les mardis soir
il passe
il est bruyant ce quartier bah attends
les manifs tu vas voir
elle est magnifique on va passer devant
chez toi tu vas être heureuse
voir tes dans les manifs normalement
donc ça finalement ça te fera moins
cette fois moins grand détour
non non en plus j'habite pas au premier
alors dis qui s'affole cavalier F5 pas
du tout apprécié là je vais fermer la
fenêtre j'arrive
j'ai l'impression que c'est quand même
mieux pour tout le monde cette histoire
alors
cavalier F5
et la jauge n'aime pas du tout cavalier
F5 pourquoi
on a été perturbé E4 et c'est le bon
coup apparemment non c'est pas du tout
le bon coup qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
jouer il fallait jouer G6 tout
simplement je prends
ah je prends F prends et E4 maintenant
et apparemment après qu'il prend des
quatre
fous prends des cadres il considère que
les noirs sont caramels pourquoi oui à
toi attaqué pardon ouh là
cavalier F3 kg
c'était la réfutation il a joué 4
directs et prend des quatre fous prends
des quatre
quelle est la différence maintenant avec
toi à 8 c'est que sur G6 on fait on peut
faire F6 là
bonne chance quand même
F6 et le coup on laisse prendre en H7 et
on fait quoi reprend
et non il a fait pousser 5 pardon
oulala il est pas bien notre ami Maxime
demain très fort demain monastère
menace j'ai vu là parce que j'ai mis les
variantes de la main notre ami
l'ordinateur
et ça peut être très chaud pour Maxime
Damart
continue à attaquer menaçage 6 qui est
ici ce qui se passe
ici c'est pas mal
ça peut tenir cette histoire peut-être
dame C3 quand même embêtant
ça peut être très chaud
peut-être pas peut-être qu'on peut
s'infiltrer aussi par là
c'est 5 aussi pour garder le contact
avec la tour pour pas faciliter le
développement de du cavalier
alors fousser 5 quelles sont les autres
options
en tout cas la maxime qui a déjà eu
chaud dans son cabinet accepté donc
c'était pas extraordinaire cette
ouverture
ratée mais pour l'instant pas trop puni
un petit peu mais pas trop non plus ça
peut être beaucoup beaucoup plus grave
s'il avait joué G6 d'abord chaque réars
de 4 ici
c'était assez catastrophique pour pour
Maxime mais heureusement plus de peur
que de mal et on en est là et Damas est
le meilleur coup d'après l'ordinateur
qui montre un avantage de 0,80 ce qui
est quand même assez conséquent
non te tiendra au courant pour les
petites Cannes à SOS on attend que
notre géo notre gentille organisatrice
Elena rentre du Mexique
c'est prévu une petite canaille un tour
à petite canaille après
faut que la faut que la géo rentre du
Mexique voilà c'est ça le
c'est ça le programme donc courant
octobre
il faut il garde de fou
il garde le fou et en même temps ça a du
sens de garder le fou cette grande
diagonale est belle elle est belle cette
grande diagonale peut-être H6 va venir
peut-être j'ai 6 on garde toutes les
options c'est pas mal
c'est quoi un petit canaille c'est le
tournoi ou on avait l'habitude de
réaliser tournoi là-bas alors moins
qu'avant mais quand même quelques-uns
c'est un bar parisien une brasserie
parisienne où il nous accueille pour
jouer des tournois
il y a une ambiance fort sympathique
alors
comment on fait il va falloir sortir les
pièces quand même faut sortir ce
cavalier et cette tour elle nous fait
peur cette tour ah c'est l'enfer
franchement son comité accepté là il se
passe mal
alors cahier cette certainement et sur
G6 cavalier F6 un truc comme ça
ça tire les céréales
je suis fatigué faut faire ça ça et ça
donc
pas sûr même si c'est aussi peut-être
pour me lancer chèque d'abord
Maxime c'est le coup humain évidemment
on peut pas faire cavalier 5 et il y a
le fou qui contrôle la grande diagonale
ne pas oublier les fous quand ils sont
loin c'est pas pour ça qu'il ne contrôle
pas la grande diagonale et là
c'est le cas
d'un E2 jouer très vite dame de cou
logique menace de coulisser quoi que par
heure
logique mais bon ça manque un peu de
peps tout ça c'est bizarre de dire ça en
parlant de chaque criard lui qui n'en
manque pas de peps et dames c'est 7
jouer madame G3 d'un F4 peut-être on
chatouille par là
est vraiment la menace
apparaîtra mais dans le clouage
mais je crois qu'on va être obligé de le
faire quand même
alors
mc7 comment on peut faire à part ça roi
champ peut-être je vois pas la
différence profonde entre roi G2 roi
champ plutôt roi jet d'eau au feeling
pour protéger F2 et
éventuellement il y a des cas il y a des
mondes où on joue tour à champ et c'est
pas bon du tout moi j'ai deux parce que
la F4 certainement et me prend S5 ouh là
là donc là
et d'un F3 il vient de jouer
et oui c'est aperçu de ça évidemment que
dame F4 était une énorme menace le coup
d'av4 et donc il a préféré faire de la
F3
ok ok
ça gagne du temps est-ce qu'on gagnerait
pas ce temps pour pour essayer de faire
ça alors attention
ce qui va faire assez mal
et non toujours pas
ce qu'on a ça non on n'a pas ça je sais
pas ce qu'on a je comprends je comprends
rien je mets à jauge F5 waouh
j'aimerais bien jouer ton à 8 est-ce que
c'est bon pas ouh là là il y a le masque
cachée
7 et comment on fait pour protéger G7 et
on peut pas ça qu'on perd une pièce si
simple que ça puisse paraître ah non il
ADM G4 pardon
c'est comme ça qu'on peut une pièce V4
le fou doit reculer dame prend et vous
prend
donc attention après d'un F3 avec cette
menace cachée de dame C3 qui est très
très jolie
est-ce que cavalier E5 est un coup ici
apparemment la jauge moufte pas même ces
trois c'est quoi la c'est quoi le délire
F2
et ça c'est pas clair du tout
et sur dame G3 qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce qu'on est cloué quand même
très très chaud
toujours un peu inquiet pour cette tour
Maxime qui prend beaucoup de temps mais
elle est pas facile à jouer cette
position 3 minutes de moins attention
Maxime comment savoir ses cheveux se ce
hicc au dessus
au dessus de sa tête voilà il surveille
plus la coiffure là il a d'autres
problèmes il a d'autres problèmes à
régler tandis que Magnus Carson est-ce
qu'il est en contrôle Magnus on va voir
ça tout de suite et Magnus qui est moins
bien aussi on pourra deux armaidons
le tapis dans son dans son idolf
apparemment bon c'est pas terminé
mais on pourra voir au moins un
Armageddon
parce que les deux joueurs qui mènent
sont en difficulté
c'est souvent comme ça
ouais électricité statique chez mvl tout
à fait E5 ouh là là 5 qu'est-ce qu'on
aime pas 5
quoi que quoi est-ce qu'on aime on
n'aime pas 5 pourquoi on n'aime pas 5
est-ce qu'on perdrait pas un pion déjà
minimum
minimum pas du tout minimum je raconte
je raconte n'importe quoi je ne vois
plus rien ce système que ça quel est le
coup je regarde la MG3
ok donc j'ai 3 suivi de H6
le cinquième coup en vrai 5 c'est un
coup possible il y a je vais foudre
est-ce que c'est bon ou pas elle dit
quoi notre jauge l'oracle l'oracle et
c'est pas mal fou des 6 ça empêche
d'ams3 ça menace des petites choses par
là ça sur contrôle la case de 5 ou
j'aime bien
j'aime beaucoup
les voir c'est coup et peut-être faut
cinq aussi pour échanger les fous de
case noire parce que ce fou est vraiment
embêtant là-bas alors maintenant
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur G6 c'est
toujours F5
c'est pas du tout le coup certainement
faute 4 alors c'est le problème
certainement ou alors peut-être échec
d'abord il faut F4 ça peut être pas mal
ça rend quelque part
attaque le cavalier et il faut prendre
le 4 qui peut arriver
intéressant
non non il perd pas c'est hyper ce match
déjà faut qu'il perde cette partie et
l'Armageddon donc ça quand même ça reste
un cas
on n'a pas encore perdu si on perd
celle-là il joue quand même demain
mais dans le loser bracket ça sera une
grosse déception évidemment
d'un E3 touche la tour tour à 8 je vois
tempo et ça y est on est revenu on est
bien revenu il y a pas de F4 là F4 ou C5
minimum donc ça serait quand même dur
envisager cavalier F3 ouais ça c'est
logique c'est pas mal joué de la part de
chakria c'est certain en plus menace
tour C1 éventuellement laisse Wave 4
mais faute 4 peut-être d'amener 4 menace
maths
[Musique]
ça perd ça serait pas bon du tout
comment on fait sur cavalier F3 jeunesse
absolument rien elle est elle est
bouillante cette position on va acheter
de faire un petit coup de petit coup
ouais un petit coup petit coup j'essaie
de tenir tant bien que mal
contre chaque criards
et légal
c'est légal on a envie de jouer
il faut calculer chose comme ça mais ça
ça a l'air bien pour les pour les blancs
en vrai parce que la finale avec cette
tour le cavalier un peu aux fraises
ça paraît complexe pour les Noirs donc
cavalier F3
jouer par ma média attention 4 minutes
d'avance pour chaque rire ma média off
c'est chaud c'est chaud tour C8 tout
simplement ton C8 mais j'ai peur moi de
maintenant il y a quand même beaucoup de
pièces là
comment on fait exactement j'en sais
rien
donc il nous trouve des bons coups là
elle est très dur je sais de position
avec mes doigts honnêtement on est sous
pression
on est sous énormes pression est-ce que
vous c'est ça qui est un coup
pour SIDAM bouge
il a joué 5 pardon dame C3
cavalier si ça tempo géant
tout simplement mais quel talent non
évidemment
cavalier H2 vous prend un 4 F3 et vous
prend G1 et abandon
superbe combinaison trouvé par Maxime ma
chaîne tous ces cinq dames C3 c'est ça
qui gagne
et cavalier F6 c'est magnifique salut a
pris beaucoup de temps alors attention
un énorme dame G3
oh là là il est pas bien du tout chakra
il a raté ça
et ce roi G2 il se passe quoi
sur roi G2 il se passe quoi
la F4 certainement d'un F4 et oui c'est
terminé
que c'est bien joué que c'est bien joué
l'homme en forme Maxime le seul qui peut
poser des problèmes à Magnus Carlsen
c'est clair maintenant c'est
complètement évident ohlala fous c'est
ça qui a été dur à jouer cette position
vous voyez il a plus que 4 minutes mais
il a trouvé un truc extraordinaire
et bien c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
vas-y propose un coup sur xLo
attention va y avoir du faux point F2
maintenant et si on fait on reprend il
faut qu'elle prend le 4 la dame peut
venir en G3
terminé de j'ai terminé
je vois pas de quoi après cavalier
et je retriche et je regarde quel est le
meilleur coup pour les blancs et
l'évaluation le meilleur coup c'est à me
5 et c'est moins 130 pour les Noirs
c'est terminé comme prévu
c'est fini
dame 5 dame 5 ouais mais tu as regardé
le coup de l'ordi ouais mais tu vois
bien la meinque
ça fou prend il y a le cavalier en prise
donc ça va pas donc il doit jouer cahier
prend et là au pire du pire on a
on a ça ça c'est pas mal quand même ça
c'est bien et on va faire fou F5 pion de
plus paire de fou alors peut-être qu'on
la gagne pas mais on s'en moque on n'est
pas là pour ça il y a pas un cas où je
vous donne 5 chaque rire voilà c'est
annoncé
vouloir entendu ici en premier
il y a pas de cas où je donne il préfère
abandonner que de jouer dames 5 voilà
donc voilà vous le savez c'est soit
abandon est plus probable que
5 c'est sûr il y a pas 5 qui apparemment
une boulette
pourquoi c'est une boulette
bac
c'est évident que les prends 4
avant bon
alors juste une minute pourquoi dame B2
comment terminer
ait il y a toujours des 8 pour faire
fout des quatre
et c'est fini tôt il a gagné Maxime
Vacher Lagrave bravo à lui et il mène
donc ça fait trois pour Maxime
et bravo à lui on va aller voir tout de
suite
je vais récupérer les images
de Magnus et de Yann les pomyachi bravo
à lui super combinaison ce cavalier F6
magnifique qui sera en finale magnifique
cavalière très très bien joué il fallait
jouer 4 et accepter d'échanger ses fous
mais évidemment il n'avait pas envie
donc il a profité de la tactique
magnifique dame C3 KFC très important à
voir et très joli il est en finale
il est en finale il attend le vainqueur
de Magnus Carson face à
créer à ma média on va tout de suite
aller récupérer la partie entre Magnus
Carlsen et on va changer les petits noms
et on voit la position voilà récupérer
ici aussi là qui va essayer de faire
vite et ça peut être évident
on va récupérer la position du live et
la position de ça donc il y a des
pommiers elle est blanc
et on va tout de suite aller les
récupérer dans le call zoom
on va des épingler tout ça
[Musique]
on va passer au plat et on va
tout de suite mettre épingler
manuscarsen
et vous allez voir sous vos yeux ébahis
sous vos yeux ébahis par la technique
improbable de faire aussi vite
on a Manu scars ici
qui a les noirs
du côté de Magnus qui souffre notre ami
Magnus
et on voit tous les pions qui avancent
là c'est pas bon ça
c'est pas bon du tout
mais on a Magnus et du coup on va aller
on va voir donc les pions qui avancent
par là les pions de Yann les pomyashi
et
les points donc c'est plus mvl c'est
Magnus cars on va changer tout ça aussi
manuscrite
et donc on va
tout de suite changer son nom
il est où son petit nom
il est là
après ça fait trop long il y a une peau
contre Magnus Carlsen
et peut-être qu'on va avoir un
Armageddon si
Magnus perd cette partie de 1 et on voit
il défend cette finale
qui est certainement perdante d'après la
jauge en tout cas pour 4 attention on
veut encaisser ce pion peut-être échec
intéressante tour cavalier et fou contre
dame trois pions
alors est-ce que c'est gagnant ou pas et
bien je n'en sais rien
en tout cas ce qui est important
c'est le vainqueur de ce match jouera
des Fira mvl dès demain
le perdant dans le loser bracket
3 et on attaque ça et on attaque ça
donc
protège le pion évidemment
elle est Ardure cette finale
elle est très très dure cette finale
clairement
Toro 3 roi B4 et tout le 4 évidemment
Maxime Magnus qui est d'accord pour la
nul
évidemment
mais les pots qui va tout faire pour
essayer de l'emporter
passionnant de cette finale c'est
dommage que les gens et pas plus de
temps là c'est en
regrette un peu le manque de temps
dure pour qui elle est dure pour pour
les noirs
pour les blancs pardon pour les Noirs
oui les bleus blancs des vrais chances
de gains ici avec des pions passés là on
est un coup de un coup de faire très mal
avec ce genre de choses
pas pour l'instant parce qu'il est tombé
3 mais l'inconvénient c'est qu'il y a un
autre pion ici qui peut menacer donc on
peut se prendre une marée de pions des
deux côtés
donc c'est quand même très délicat comme
final voir perdant j'en sais rien si
c'est pendant ou pas à mon avis ça va
fluctuer ce genre de choses
alors comment il fait Magnus il
réfléchit faut pas se mettre mal au
temps non plus parce que trois secondes
par coup ça suffit pas pour trouver des
solutions mais en même temps moi je suis
bien malin de parler ici mais c'est pas
évident à jouer cette position parce que
B6 est une énorme menace j'ai 6 j'ai
l'impression aussi quoi que j'essaie sur
a peut-être toi aussi
d'après la jauge
et B6 à mon avis hein et ben si je
jouais menace B7 et B8 dame attention
il a l'air il a l'air content il y a des
pommiers
on va certainement avoir
on va avoir
un Armageddon
il a joué le feu Magnus la joie alors
que il a besoin que d'une nul alors
effectivement il est en grosse confiance
il a envie de se tester mais bon quand
même c'est pas niveau du résultat c'est
peut-être pas
pour ramasser les deux pions sur échec
et l'autre comme ça
ouh là là peut-être qu'il a une idée de
forteresse en tête
elle est pas fini cette partie au final
ça c'est clair est-ce qu'il a mieux que
ça est-ce qu'il réfléchit la dame C7 et
G7
j'en sais rien
est-ce que ça ça gagne ou pas
absolument aucune idée
je vais tenté de dire oui mais bon et il
a pas il a pas fait
et j'ai 7 maintenant vas-y je termine un
autre ton G6
et il va avoir cette finale de toute
façon
j'essaie de va arriver évidemment il
faut se débarrasser et maintenant et
maintenant le petit train et je crois
qu'on va être obligé même si on arrive à
donner le cavalier quand le pion ça sera
un bon deal ton G6 sur A6 il y a tombé
si c'est chèque donc ça ça serait quand
même pas très malin mais il est pas fou
il joue assez d'eux il menace assis
maintenant
si il veut faire tomber 6 je suppose
et encore ça mesdames à 8h à 7 peut-être
ou dans ma tête ah ça a l'air gagnant
mais il faut encore montrer de la
précision
et c'est pas évident
voilà mais qui c'est qui est-ce qu'il y
a des modos là sur sur twitch s'il vous
plaît j'ai pas mon compte là Zlatan
warning you
[Musique]
oui
s'il y a des modos moi je suis modo mais
j'ai pas mon compte là ouvert
S 5
et
roi des œufs je crois et à 7
il fait tourner
à 8 il va faire à 7 au prochain coup ton
cu8 certainement ok je vais sur le coup
pour pas perdre il fait pas
l'élimination pour pas perdre tout de
suite en tout cas manuscarlsen j'ai
l'impression Dame des cinq là quand même
mais est-ce que c'est efficace parce que
kb6 cavalier à 8 tours
donc dommage 5 maintenant et comment il
veut faire
je le vois pas le truc il a l'air de
vouloir faire un escalier et lui Magnus
évidemment s'il met son roi par là ça va
être nul donc faut qu'il fasse attention
les pots une fois de plus il pourrait se
faire avoir par le grand Magnus
comment on fait là j'en sais rien
je sais pas comment on fait et 22
secondes c'est pas mon point ça il
arrive plus à gagner
il fait non de la tête
il sait qu'il doit être gagnant
le roi de revenir
et maintenant il va ramener le roi il va
faire roisser 7 attention cab8
le roi vient juste à temps
et comment on fait maintenant pour
progresser certainement un échec par là
non dame B4 plus ou moins exang en
menace dame D4 attention ok bébé
non
dame prend un 7 mais il est trop fort il
est trop fort Magnus sur les pièges qui
tend c'est du délire sur roi B5 donc 3D
8 et maintenant comment on fait
Dame des 4
ça se termine en roi dame contre retour
je vais le remontrer au ralenti ce piège
il était extraordinaire Dame des saints
qui va faire on va prendre 8 ans en roto
contre Adam ça gagne mais regardez-moi
ça regardez le piège qui lui a tendu et
sur
ici et roi B6 et qui prend un set et on
reprend à 7 et roisser ça va être mieux
et maintenant on a roi dame contre roi
tour mais il a réussi à encaisser la
tour en faisant ça c'était fabuleusement
bien joué et roi B7 maintenant c'était
bien joué les deux côtés
maintenant normalement un joueur de la
classe de Yann les pomyachi va savoir
comment gagner ça attention la règle des
50 coups
attention à ça c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini
oh là là les pièges qui tend
et pour gagner c'est parti envoyer un à
quel point
à quel point c'est dur de gagner une
partie des chèques contre manuscrit ça
rigole pas
parce que franchement
il faut il faut se lever de bonheur et
piège qui tend avec deux secondes à la
pendule alors on en a combien de coup là
en été au 80 78e coup il y a eu la
dernière prise on en est à 91
donc à on va faire un 79 + 50 à 129
coups la partie sera déclarée nulle
si je me trompe pas d'un calcul qui sont
pas très compliqué alors 5 ça c'est bien
ouais fuite et maintenant en général le
truc c'est de d'avoir la dame sur la
alors oui parce que là typiquement si on
fait ça on se prend des échecs
donc faut arriver à faire un truc du
genre
je suis pas sûr de la gagnant
honnêtement
MG5 tours
mais ouais roi des 7 et une bien
meilleure défense tout recettes perdait
trop simplement
il a l'air de patauger il a mis une
épaule
alors attention il y a un piège si on
fait ça ça si on fait ça c'est nul alors
je vais montrer le piège c'est petit
piège hop
bon évidemment c'est pas pour ces deux
joueurs
ils tombent pas dans ce genre de pièce
ordama 3 damma 3 normalement c'est pas
ce qu'il faut faire là il patauge
mais alors complet
est-ce qu'ils peuvent faire d'un bv8 Mb4
et roi E6 ça me semble mieux quand même
genre ça d'accord
c'est pas du tout la bonne technique là
il n'arrive pas à le coller au coin faut
le coller faut le coller par là
normalement le roi
parce que là on s'en sort pas mais c'est
pas évident avec trois secondes
d'incrément simplement
on la voit aussi c'est toujours la même
hein tout recettes et tout aussi c'est
la même défense
15 secondes pour
la gagner ça va être joué certainement 8
plus que 25 coups
alors la dame sur la quatrième
normalement c'est la bonne stratégie
pourquoi il a pas fait échec là et roi
parce qu'ils 0 à 8 encore et il a défend
bien m'amuse jamais
mais alors
attention plus que 20 coups pour prendre
un tour
ça peut se terminer ici et maintenant
plus que 20 coups pour prendre la tour
19 18
il y a combien de spécialiste en défense
exact il a défend contre fierté
au centre pourquoi parce que peut-être
que elle envisage la règle des 50 coups
aussi
c'est terrible pour un époux qui arrive
pas du tout à la gagner là il reste plus
que 12 coups
dans 12 coups ça sera déclaré nul
ça il doit tout refaire depuis le début
il est complètement humilié dans cette
finale mais objectivement ça gagne plus
ça gagne plus pourquoi parce que il y a
eu trop de coups jouets et la jauge
prend en compte ça
il l'a défendu comme un chef
incroyable
incroyable il a bien ah ouais il a
défendu j'ai jamais vu ça ouais moi j'ai
jamais eu en pratique
heureusement
mais quand de Magnus j'ai l'impression
qu'il a défend vraiment bien il reste
trois coups pour lui prendre la tour
donc autant vous dire que
c'est a priori c'est mort il ne s'est
peut-être pas Magnus il a peut-être pas
les coups devant lui mais il doute qu'il
est pas loin et
il sourit Magnus Carcen il peut il a pas
du tout réussi à gagner oh là là il est
parti alors là il est parti et il
applaudit
il a hyper bien défendu c'était assez
incroyable
ce qu'il a fait
et envoie à manus qui est content il
peut être content ou un épaules il est
parti
il est parti n'est pas et Magnus Carlsen
évidemment
qui
est bien on l'a on l'a on a rêvé on est
arrivé alors en le disant ou secrètement
mais on a une finale Carlsen va chez
Lagrave alors ça veut pas dire que le
vainqueur gagne le tournoi et c'est là
le vainqueur est très bien le vainqueur
et au pire deuxième du tournoi donc déjà
c'est
c'est quand même très beau
donc on aura Magnus Carcen Maxime
vachererave pour une place en finale
vendredi est-ce que le perdant sera
reversé dans le loser bracket et dans le
loser bracket on aura
ma meilleure vie et notre petit qui va
récupérer les paumes
c'est pas mal pour nous
donc le programme de demain
c'est très simple c'est d'abord à
l'IRISA qu'on n'est pas dit à partir de
18h et à partir de 20h comme aujourd'hui
on aura Maxime machinagrafe à sa Magnus
Carl scène la grande finale
ensuite jeudi on espère
on espère évidemment avoir au moins un
français
voir au plus parce que si Maxime gagne
est directement dans la grande finale
mais voilà on est il reste plus que 6
joueurs et on a toujours nos deux
Français effectivement il pouvait pas
tout gagner les deux mais
puisqu'ils vont ensemble mais Maxime
gros match et clairement
honnêtement c'est je pense alors
effectivement manuscrit dans une forme
olympique en ce moment mais c'est
peut-être
Maxime qui peut lui poser des problèmes
s'il y a quelqu'un qui peut lui poser
problème ça sera Maxime ça c'est une
évidence parce que tellement il joue
bien ces derniers temps et donc on va
suivre ça vraiment avec beaucoup
d'intérêts des 18 heures il y a quand
même une époque fille rougea qui est
quand même sympa à regarder et donc on
le regardera je serai là au même endroit
à la même heure avec la même maestria
technique
et à partir de 20 heures pour suivre 20
heures à peu près vous avez compris dès
que ça finit on recommence l'autre donc
19h40 10h50 pour mvl face à Magnus
Carson la grande finale à quatre parties
donc ça sera on va se régaler de A à Z
merci beaucoup merci infiniment pour vos
commentaires pour vos LIKES
et pour
pour m'avoir suivi surtout et
ouais je vais retrouver mes codes de
modo aussi et voilà et je vous dis à
demain pour une grande finale
qui sera forcément
belle à suivre une bonne soirée une
bonne nuit à tout le monde ciao ciao
[Musique]